foreign
ladies and gentlemen uh welcome to this
meeting of uh torridge council's
internal overview and scrutiny committee
and I would start by welcoming
councilors who weren't able to attend at
our previous meeting and it's good to
see a nearly Full House I think I think
we're just minus one
um
so we'll start straight away first of
all apologies for absence thank you
chair no apologies received thank you
Kirsty uh moving next to the minutes of
the last meeting
um
and for new councils I remind you that
if you if you if you weren't present
then you have no option but to abstain
when we come to approve them so turning
to the agenda on this is the agenda page
and I'll just read through the the page
numbers somebody shout to put their hand
up if there is an issue or they want to
raise something page three
page four
page five
Page Six
page seven
page eight
and page nine
councilor bright you have a uh thank you
yeah I just spotted that the um the
meeting
opened at 2PM and it closed at 12 30 a.m
this new committee we're very quick
um thank you for that uh typo correctly
have you got that person
um so for those who and I just remind
myself for those who are present can I
have a show of uh those in favor of
those minutes please
so does somebody propose that I'm sorry
uh councilor craigie and have a seconder
councilor Lobel uh so all in favor
please
and that is unanimous of those who are
here
everybody else abstaining presumably
thank you
um moving moving on to the action list
the action list at the moment is blank
um and um
on that thank you chair yeah the last
meeting it was agreed that we'd set up a
task and finish group to look at social
value
um we are still waiting for the
procurement Bill to go through
the legislative stages but it is time
really for us to get ready for that so
we've got
um probably a social value
drafted that we'll need to go to CNR for
approval
and so far we've got uh three
um
counselors and a councilor craigie
counselor Hodson and Mr good dengate
volunteer to be on the task and finish
group to look at social value and then
to draft a
social value policy to bring to this
committee for approval before it goes to
CNR and it was whether or not there was
any other counselors wanting to be on
the committee check
thanks John ideally I'd like one extra
counselor on on on this uh this working
group
um
it's an interesting and important area
it's an emerging area
and that we we started in the last
period
um and we had some external
presentations and it was it was very
interesting it is subject to as John
mentioned government legislation coming
through which is still in the
still in the creation at the moment I
think but it is something that's going
to increasingly affect the work we do
so do we have uh another counselor at
this time or independent member who
would like to join that group
okay we'll leave it as it is for time
being it's going to be um
that that that that was a reluctant hand
uh
all right good uh that's fine if that's
that gives us four which is which is uh
what I'd like
um I asked councilor craigie at the last
meeting whether he would be prepared to
to chair that group and he agreed
um uh Mr dengate who was previously on
the
um the the group so he will bring
continuity across and then councilor
Hodgson has emailed me to volunteer and
now councilor cotton that makes the
group
um do we need to say more at this stage
no
um
I did query whether there are or there
were terms of reference
um when we set the group up previously
I'm told that people don't think there
are terms of reference previously
um and we will we will think offline as
to whether
um uh there needs to be terms of
reference or a degree of guidance given
to the subgroup and I'll we'll come back
on that one what's
I guess that's the right thing to do
it's a task and finish group so uh it's
for the committee you just agree the
terms of reference so if the the group
meets and brings those terms of
reference back to the committee for
agreement
I think that's actually probably that
and and
um
I know Steve dengate was was was well
into the the process last time and
perhaps with yourself
um
um James if you come back to us with
with a what do you think uh ought to be
um the terms of reference and I'm sure
we will have no problems um agreeing
with that
um but um it's it's quite a loose um
tasking away at the moment because
nobody quite knows how we're going to
quantify and measure and therefore it's
aided and guided by uh
legislation which I think will very much
in the main say the requirement for it
but it may not be too specific in it
telling us exactly how we we we achieve
it so it'll be interesting to see where
that comes
I haven't spoke to John's just about
John or an officer with a working group
just so that we could capture it and
make sure understand how it fits in with
the rest of the council
uh thanks very much on that
um moving on then to item number nine
the census and statistics update
um
this was partially sprung by councilor
Hodgson who who's not here this evening
sadly
it's an area of fascinating and detailed
information which many of us counselors
I have to admit slightly passed over in
the past
um and um so I've asked John to
give us a bit more detail on it and then
we can discuss it
foreign
I've got a few slides to run through
so
before I go in into the the census
information this was um brought up at
the last meeting and asked to give a
little bit of background information to
the committee about the kind of the
statistics and the census information
affecting torridges and area and to give
councilors a bit of background for when
they're looking at their their forward
plan
um what I will say I've done it by
exception so
it's all kind of bad news because I
haven't done all the good stuff because
we haven't got time so please
bear with me
I am painting the bad news because it is
by exception so to kind of really wanted
to say that to you all so census day was
the 21st of March 2021
and it was just under 60 million people
in England and Wales
this was the largest population ever
recorded it was really high response
rate of 97 and for the first time ever
it was uh the highest amount of
responses was online so that's the the
the first time that's ever happened the
population grew by 3.5 percent across
the country and I'll show you a tiny bit
about storage in a minute
um and that was and the highest
population growth was in the east of
England which rose by 8.3 percent
just over 30 million of women were in
the census that's 51 and 49 men
there were more people than ever before
in the older age groups and that's
something I'm going to cover in a little
bit when we go into more detail for
torrage so those age 65 and over was
18.6 percent uh in in England and Wales
and that was 16.4 in 2011.
and there were 24 782
000 households and that was an increase
of 1.4 million so that's just a bit of
background about the census
there's been a census every 10 years
since 1801 except for
1941 when there wasn't one because of
the war
and you would just see by that chart
kind of the the growth of population
across the country from that time
now I I guess you all knew this but the
very first census in 1801
um was set up to check that there was
enough bread production for the nation
so that was 1801 2021 was the first
digital first census and May well be the
last ever census because the information
below the there's consultation going on
now about
um and I only went to a seminar about it
yet last week about whether they should
continue with census or whether that
information is out of date quite quickly
and whether they should look at what
they term administrative data which is
data that they get from other sources so
I'm going to circulate these slides
after but if anybody's interested in
that there's a link to the um
consultation
so
in storage we ranged had an increase of
6.7 up to 68 100.
um
what I said earlier about the Aging
population you'll see here this these
two charts side by side of the
population change by age group
on the left hand side is England and on
the right hand side of torridge
so what you'll see here is what we're
talking about the Aging population for
Torrid and you'll see there that that's
quite significantly more than the kind
of Aging population for England
what I'm showing you there is kind of
the decrease in those working age
so there's a decrease there of the
working age
sometimes known as a brain drain so
you'll see there that that's kind of
obviously going to affect our our
working age
a cohort and
the last one I've circulated there
you'll see the kind of the 50s the the
the growing uh number of 50s and and I
raised that because there was quite a
lot of publicity around though that age
range retiring early and again if that
was happening that would also affect our
economy and and what we've got
um but I guess the Striking
um
stat there and I've highlighted it in
red is that there's been a decrease of
0.6 percent in people age between 15 and
64.
so you see that that's quite uh quite an
interesting stat there and there's
something to to bear in mind
and the increase in in children aged
under 15 was only 1.6 percent
uh what this means for for storage is
the median age has rage raised from 47
in the last census 2011 up to 51 years
now so that's a four-year increase in
those 10 years
um
only 32 of the 309 local authorities uh
have had an increase of over 30 percent
of those aged over 65.
and you see there that torrage one of
those one of those councils
so I'm just going to start building a
little picture for you all here so
that's kind of the the age profile and
and the stats so now the labor market
well
nationally
This was
um the top five so it's retail Education
Health construction and public admin so
that was
um and the biggest mover was computer
from kind of 14th up to eighth those
working in computers and the biggest
decrease nationally was in financial
services from 13th down to 10th so now
I'll show you what that means for
torrage so the top five in torridge
Health and Social care
wholesale retail and re repair Motor
Vehicles construction education and
Manufacturing it will show you some
other bits and you might not see there
but as I say when I circulate the slides
you'll be able to see that more
so this is the one that um I'm thinking
Mr Harper might might enjoy because he
sent me the link
um and this is one that really really
surprised me
so over the years and and probably most
of the time I've been doing stats for
torrage we've always been very very low
in our full-time gross weekly pay for
the for the area and we've put that in
our stats about you know lowest second
lowest and all of that
we'll look at if you can look at that
blue bottom blue line and how that shot
up since 2020 we're now out of those 300
plus councils we're now 83rd instead of
second wears so that is a really big
increase at
completely honest I wasn't expecting
until I saw those stats
um
so that's something else and the red one
I've put in there is Devin just to show
you how we have closed that Gap
um for the the kind of the the gross
weekly pay
um for them because we were as you'll
see even in 2020 we were there was a big
gap there
um so that previous one was place of
work and this one is very similar this
is place of residence so where you live
where you earn your money where you live
um and you'll see for this one very
similar stats but actually
um torridge is overtaken the Devon
average for where you live so that's an
interesting little take on it as well
and as I said what wasn't really
expecting that we've always been a
little bit lower
yeah could you explain what that one
means this this one is where people
where that what they earn of where they
live rather than where they work so the
stat is so if you if if I lived in
torridge but worked in North Devon my
stat would be here but if on the
previous slide it'll be it would be
recorded as as North Devon
does that does that help
yeah okay
um
so we've also heard about the population
um on on Universal Credit so I've got a
few stats on on some some more kind of
different angles here so we're the third
highest
um population on Universal Credit are
those age 16 to 65
um and that's out of the Southwest
councils
we've got a high proportion
um claiming pension credit sorry about
this slide there it didn't it didn't
come out very well as I said I will
circulate this so probably not
surprising obviously because of our
aging population but the pension credit
side of those 65 plus so again the
highest of our sit for near
neighborhoods
and um
moving on to fuel poverty now so this
one's looking at fuel poverty
um from our near neighbors again we're
we're the second highest there so again
I'm building this this picture for you
about kind of the issues facing facing
the area
um I know
um we've had some discussions about
um cold poverty
um and this stack kind of shows child
poverty over the last few years
and how we rate amongst amongst the
others and obviously that's a really
high increase over the last few years or
over the last year particularly
um what we can do and and I won't go
into it but this is showing
um the the uh child poverty or
relatively low income for households per
Ward so you know if there are things
that obviously members want to look at
in more detail than we can Dig Down
Deeper as I say this is just your top
level to give you an idea of start
thinking of things that you want to add
to your forward plan but that just shows
um kind of a the last I think it's five
years one two three six years per award
um so that gives you an idea there
and again you can even Dig Down Deeper
so this is kind of super accurate area
so we can Dig Down Deeper and the darker
the color the bigger the increase
um from 2021 to 20 21 22. so it just
gives you a little flavor there of of
some of the areas what that's um that's
seen this issue
um and then we're looking at the
economically active
um and we're saying now that actually
we've had a decrease of 3.5 percent
since the last
um
census and you'll see there that
actually where we're at the darker the
colors against the country there you'll
see
um the worst of performance so we're not
we're not that bad but actually you know
a decrease isn't good
um economically inactive you look at the
the actual bar chart at the bottom there
the the range are all the councils in
the country
so kind of in the if you're in the
middle you're in the middle of the in
the country and the extremes are the
extremes so you'll see for economically
inactive
um we we are in the higher proportion of
of kind of the stats for that
of those we've got to obviously and and
we we saw earlier that the hyper
proportion of those are aging now and
we've got a high proportion of of
retired people in the area
uh what else we we can see from these
stats is that we have a very high
proportion of part-time workers so
that's a lot more than a lot of the
other areas and where these work 15
hours or less on this stat so you see
we're still high on this but this next
step we are nearly which is 16 to 30
hours you know we are right up there
amongst it for
um for those that work part-time and
again that brings you know an effect on
on the employment Market
well obviously that shows is we've got a
very low percentage of part-time people
working 31 to 48 hours in comparison to
the rest of the country you'll see the
you know 49 for torrage and the lowest
in the country is 47.7 so that gives you
again a little little flavor
um
the skills trade yep sorry
which is
sorry Council yes
yeah
no it doesn't it doesn't it doesn't show
that
also would the statistics be able to
pick up if if it's a choice to work
part-time or not
the these stats don't go into that much
detail
um I'm not sure whether we could find
something that does do that these are
purely from the questionnaires in the
census so they were very kind of
straight down the middle really you know
kind of how you how you work and
whatever so it's not Choice
um it'd be an interesting one to try to
dig out and I'm not sure that I I could
find that but it would be interesting
so the the next the next slide here is
set this is one of the biggest kind of
Trades and that's skill trade so 18.8 of
of the population or the working age
population
um
are in a skilled trading storage so
that's an interesting stat bearing in
mind that the top percentage in the
country's 19.8 so we are top very top in
in the skill trade which is a good good
stat
um the other high one but not as high as
the last one was the occupation around
caring Leisure and other
service occupations again you'll see
that's a the high stat
another one that I found really
interesting
um was the the really high percentage of
um self-employed in the torridge area so
these are from the very latest stats
from Noma so these are December 2022 and
um we are the second highest of all the
councils in the south west uh being
self-employed again I'm just trying to
start building a picture for you I was
just wondering how many councils are
there in the south west So when you say
second how many is that out of
oh is it that
oh I've got it
these are the these are out of the 14
districts so they're comparable to us
yeah yeah safe West comparable of the
Southwest
so then we're looking at education just
have a quick scroll through some of the
the education these are the South West
these are showing uh 16 to 64.
um qualified to at least level three or
higher and you'll see there we've got
the lowest of the the South West
District district councils there
and then looking at it from against our
sit for near Neighbors which the
Electoral um not the
um government kind of map us against in
the LGA like to like us to use this
comparison you'll see there we're kind
of the you know lower end again and kind
of third lowest
um we do have which is kind of good we
do have one of the highest rates of um
apprenticeships which is good for for
the area and you'll see that compared
nationally along the bottom we are in
that top top 20 percent
life expectancy
um this was quite an interesting one
there's quite a disparity
yeah that word sorry
um between our lowest Ward which is
Biddeford West in female and males and
and the highest so from for females
it's a 6.9
disparity with two rivers and three
Moors and for males Cheviot and Langtry
there's a 8.9
um 8.9 years difference and you'll see
there that again I am going to share
these slides so just just gives you a a
feel for Where We Are
um with the census they did some
deprivation figures and
um again quite high that uh households
deprived in one of the dimensions we
were we were quite high on that
housing some stats that you already
aware of and I've actually taken that
from your qbr end of year one you know
the average number of households living
in temporary accommodation you see that
kind of the chart and and you've heard
it at various committees and how how
that's increased considerably we've got
1616 on our housing waiting list
and and for the area we've got you know
relatively High house prices and I think
yeah kind of shows where we're where
we're at uh the medium house price
um against our sit for near neighbors so
you'll see that we're you know quite
quite High there
um so I've only got a couple of more
slides to say so in summary we've got a
aging population
with a high level claiming pension
credit
relatively low wages but looks like
that's improving high level part-time
workers High economically inactive
high level of self-employed high
percentage child poverty High fuel
poverty low level qualified to level
three or higher low gva
high percentage claiming Universal
Credit
High numbers in temporary accommodation
High numbers on the waiting list high
medium house prices and you know life
expectancy disparity between Awards is
relatively High
um but I have to say this because I know
I warned you at the front about doom and
groom it's not all doom and gloom and I
think this is probably my last slide but
gorgeous part of Devon named happiest
place to live in the UK that was us so
this is real just been published
so the source for the annual population
Service uh surveyed by the office for
National statistics life satisfaction
worthwhile and happiness torrid's ranked
really high so it's not all bad and
this we've got some benchmarking stats
we've provided everybody with a link to
those
um
in in previous on the agenda and
everything not going to go into that
today but once you guys start looking at
your work program we can dig more
information out and
that's it chair a quick run through
hopefully I haven't scared everybody and
happy to answer any questions
John thank you very much indeed that's
uh a fascinating Gallup through
um some of our our headline
um uh information
um I made a couple of notes as you were
going on the first said Beware raw data
um especially where percentages are used
we can't always see it but it's very
important to see what the sample size is
when you're talking percentages
so for instance
in a rural Ward that many of us have
we probably have relatively small number
of children lower number of children
than in an urban Ward where there may be
much higher number of children so when
you're actually comparing things and
you're talking broad percentage one
needs to actually try to
reinforce and quantify that with actual
detail of how many really are we talking
about
et cetera Etc but that's really useful
um
the the value to us
um is the the link that John put in the
um the agenda uh and I hope that
everybody has um taken the opportunity
of opening that link uh to have a look
at the benchmarking and especially when
we come to be looking at especially here
where uh it's now been tabulated in a
form which corresponds to the different
themes and sections within our qbr
so actually you can see in different
areas and even if you just take the the
the dashboard bit which is the the front
two pages
you can see where as a council we are
sitting compared to our
comparators now not competitors but
comparators which is this group of
councils throughout the country who
roughly make up a similar
um sample as ourselves
um
very useful and I think um especially
when we come to looking at qbr uh we we
need to make greater use of this
material that is available to us because
it is and the the
if I'm correct that the the benchmarking
gets updated on an annual basis
um it's either every year or every
couple of years depending on on how what
information we can obtain so it's not
it's not like the census which is only
once every 10 years and and maybe
no more anyway uh there is a steady flow
of new information new data coming into
this so they don't the benchmarking
doesn't necessarily lose its relevance
as time goes on because um so and I'd
thank councilor Hodgson for
um pointing us towards it at the last uh
the last meeting something that possibly
quite a few of us I know I've been one
uh didn't actually really know enough
about and it's an interesting error
um
any comment on on on that um
the the wages
is that Ash you take them from because
what's interesting is it's only full
time it doesn't take into account one of
the highest Parts which are part-time
and self-employed and I think when you
start taking that in then there is an
issue there
yeah absolutely right
um
but it is a comparator that we've been
using for so long and to see that
increase as it has
um I think is is quite telling for the
area yeah
thank you chair very interesting
information uh we've just seen John and
you know thank you for that
I suppose really it's a question of
how it informs us to make any changes
and what we can actually do about it I
mean one of the very interesting
statistics that jumped out at me was the
the number of empty dwellings vacant
dwellings in torrage in 2021
925 empty dwellings which is the fourth
lowest of the 16 comparables in the in
the country which is 2.8 percent of the
total number of dwellings within the
Taurus District well you know when when
we're talking about declaring a housing
emergency
and you read a stat that we've got 925
empty dwellings
that doesn't you know it's a little bit
misleading because that doesn't mean to
say that that's 925 dwellings that
theoretically could be brought back into
occupation you know the numbers may be
much much smaller than that so it's what
we can actually do what when we've
actually got that information as an
authority
that's the interesting part
the the the great so what question uh
when somebody tells you something yeah
you know
um quite
any other counselors
thanks Jay
um well I I guess some of those
statistics are not very pleasing for for
anybody to see and it comes back to well
what are we gonna what are we as a
council going to do about some of them
now the obvious first start is looking
at our strategic plan our strategic
priorities and if you've had the chance
already to read the the full Council
report for Monday evening it sets out to
the council's timetable proposed
timetable for for doing that it comes
back to looking at our economic
strategies our our linkages with
education sector Health sector and all
of those other bodies so the first part
is for the council to determine uh how
it wants to set its agenda for the next
four years and Beyond so we'll be
sending out shortly invitations to a
strategic plan planning workshop for all
members uh to be to get involved with
certain nudge that agenda
thank you see uh
any other
any other comment on on this work at the
moment
score informing ourselves that it exists
more work yet to learn exactly what we
can do with it
where specifically it can inform us uh
and and
putting real interpretation on it just
like councilor bushby was referring to
to empty empty dwellings
for example in a rural Ward and when
one's going out leaf-litting properties
I know of quite a number of empty
properties in my ward
most of them nobody would live in even
if you you even if even if you force
them to live there that that flee
because they're miles from anywhere and
unless you've got you know your own
transportation and everything else and
their their own properties on on farms
which
um and indeed you know probably they'd
sell them if they could but they've got
no value so everything's Everything's
Relative but interesting very
interesting anything else on that one
before we move on
thank you
um
now the
the main business of this evening's
meeting and that is the
to develop our work program
and then to
start to build a forward plan in other
words what the business of this
committee over over the next two years
uh is going to be and I asked you all to
um
uh feed in
um areas or items that you thought that
this committee should be looking at
um
this is
in addition to the major standing
quarterly item that this committee looks
at which is the performance of the
council and the alignment of the council
spend against its budget namely the
quarterly Business review and the as I
said at the last meeting I'll repeat it
now for the benefit of others who are
not here if you're not a qbr bunny
please make sure you become one you
cannot sit on this committee if you do
not
understand how the qbr works and are
prepared to get into the weeds of the
qbr every time we are given one to look
at because that is the actual absolute
signposting as to how well we are doing
against our various strategies and also
with regard to how well we are doing
with regard to the amount of money that
we think we should be spending in each
area Etc and it's the qbr that
should be flagging up or we should be
finding in it
areas which are of concern normally by
exception
and if they are of sufficient concern
then it is for this committee to flag
those uh areas up uh to full Council so
if you're not across the qbr business
please make a point of doing so and John
will offer assistance to anybody who
wants to be talked through and led
through the qbr system more because it
is our absolute bread and butter of this
of this committee so
qbr appearing four times a year in our
work program is a given and we're not
going to dwell on qbr tonight it's the
question is what else are we going to
look at
um
we've had contributions from a number of
councilors and uh independent members
and I think the best way we can is to
run through these and to have a brief
discussion on each
what we're not trying to do is
answer the question what we're trying to
do is measure the importance to us how
what is the priority of something that
it appears in our work
and when if we can answer the question
now then there's no point in putting it
in a work program because it doesn't
need to be investigated so uh
refrain from getting stuck into your
thoughts about it and actually try to
look at the importance and and how
important it is
and I think if we
um
we start probably
by going through and
prioritizing each one
one two or three probably
the likelihood is that that something
that we we give a three to may not may
not make our work program
um but we we need to have a degree of
prioritization in it and it should be a
committee decision uh rather than myself
and the vice chair sitting down and
saying uh we're going to discuss this
so I would like to be guided and
informed by you as to where we should be
putting our priority the chief exec's
going to say something very quick before
we get into that that's okay excuse me
um just just before you start going into
the the detail obviously the the
headings on there and it's not clear
what the the question is to start with
on some of them some of them will be
work that's already being done or
already be in progress or being planned
to be done and obviously the other thing
we need to be mindful of the committee
needs to be mindful of is if some of the
things start to stream work of other
committees such as community and
resources because it's it's scrutiny of
decisions and things that are happening
rather than things that other committees
may be responsible for so just a couple
of caveats for all the discussion and
obviously that the constitution at the
end of the day drives what this
committee's remakes and terms of
reference are which I think as we as we
go through we might need to have a
discussion around I'm sure you will be
doing some steering chief executive
um if we could end up down a wrong
Rabbit Hole um it's hard it's hard to
tell with some of the items it is what
exactly is being asked
let's take them literally as John has
listed them there I think we've got
um and the latest the later ones have
all been added to it so
um let's um from from the start
um
relief for people who live in the area
basically we're talking about the take
up
of
Grants and and other monies which are
available this was
alluded to by councilor Pennington in
his notice some motion in full Council
and our response to that was fine he was
actually talking about pension credit we
said we want to be able to look at the
whole breadth of money that is out there
because we are frequently being told
that actually
what's that and what people are eligible
to claim often is not been done and we
need to the idea of looking at this
would be to first of all identify the
different the different areas of of
funding that's available that people can
claim
um uh and bid for secondly
to understand
the criteria of each particular type of
award because it may be that people are
are not entitled for various reasons so
we need to understand
what the criteria is for each type of
award and then to look at the
the percentage of take-up from it and
from there we then form a view as to
whether actually the percentage take up
is reasonable or is actually not good
enough
and is that and we then have to form a
view as whether that is something that
the council could be doing more in order
to whether it be advertising or or
whatever
that was the idea that came that was
behind it
I opened the floor to anybody who wants
to comment on that
I was just going to say that a lot of
that is covered in external with our
work of citizens advice and ttvs
and those types of bodies unless you're
talking about grants directly related to
storage no we're talking specifically
about torridge
money or storage
um administered money is where the where
the idea came from
well it seemed that most of the
administered money for Torrid comes
through that the housing and council tax
support doesn't it
correct
I think things things like the household
support grants like the council tax
relief I mean
um
Stacy I think you said the the other day
is it something like the household
support fund is is
always under subscribed is that
yeah I'll just clarify I think the the
one that councilor Pennington is talking
about and forgive me if I'm wrong but I
think that it's exceptional hardship
fund for the council tax scheme and he
he believes that that is under spent
um my comment on that is there's two
issues with that with the council tax
exceptional hardship scheme the majority
of people are already in receipt of
council tax support so the awards given
are low because the element of council
tax that they pay is fairly low
um but for the last at least two years
we have also had the household support
fund which has come directly from the
government via DWP
um and we've had substantial amounts of
money so this last we're on household
support fund number four we've had 160
000 with that fund and we have to spend
all of that otherwise the whole of Devon
doesn't get their allocation and that
was very clear so with this current one
we were told to spend half
um within the first six months we have
spent that and we're dead on target to
spend the other half so I think through
covid and actually coming out of covid
there's been a lot of other help
available to people
um the DWP Devon County they they set
the rules for when we can and can't pay
the grant but the support fund is very
very flexible in terms of how we can
give how help so we've tended to Veer
towards that as opposed to an
exceptional hardship scheme which is a a
small amount for a very limited period
usually for about three months and it
has to come off this year's bill it
can't go towards historic arrears as
well so we're quite hamstrung
um so with with that I I think there's
been a fairly good take up we have I
think it probably started off quite slow
but we are on target with what we've
spent and and the suggestions are
there's going to be a five and six with
with that one
the question that we were given
originally related to pension credit
are we saying that that is
within our gift or is external
chair that that's uh with the DWP that's
not something we have specific figures
or details around
as were shown on one of John slaves was
it 54 of people claiming
pension credit I think I saw so
we don't know whether that's a high or
low take-up because we don't have the
the data or statistics to determine that
comes out
thank you chair
um I think councilor Pennington was
concerned because during the campaign
for re-election
he discovered people who weren't aware
of their benefit entitlement
I think one of the issues that was
raised is the knowledge of counselors as
Ward members about the availability and
range of Grants
and things to signpost people because
there are a lot of us or maybe a lot of
us that aren't fully aware of
who and what they qualify for so I think
it's important that as a council we are
aware of those things and we have some
sort of crib sheet if people are
struggling and approaches we can refer
these people
because they're making the initial
contact we're on the ground we're in
their communities they might not think
of coming to ask for advice from housing
advice
or even citizens advice Bureau so it's
important that we have that knowledge
going back to what Stacy was saying
about the household support fund
um remind you that we ran out of money
and we actually had to top it up to
carry us over for a period of time
during the last administration because
it was well subscribed to and I think
really now people have learned about it
and because it is so flexible it is
actually serving a really good purpose
to our communities who are struggling
with all sorts of aspects so I thank the
staff for doing that because I think it
has enabled them to really help people
who are
experiencing difficulties so I think
that is perhaps one of the most flexible
ways of assisting people but I think
it's about knowledge and I think that is
really important I think what you're
saying there is is is is absolutely bang
on the money
in some form of
factual crib sheet
for counselors
um
that can be done without it having to be
looked at as an item on this on this
committee I'm coming to the view that
actually this is not an item for this
committee to look at
um
and what we're hearing from Stacy anyway
is that we're not thinking that there's
real cause for concern are we agreed
with that
is that
oh thank you yeah I was going to say
that yeah as we say uh crib sheet would
be a good sensible idea okay that's
fairly easy and then maybe give each
woman I tend to put into the village
halls or whatever you know some places
where people can see them and then do a
bit of a social media campaign on that
that sounds like a wrap up hopefully
yeah just just a couple of points just
to go back with you um I did circulate
very recently again the cost of living
um page
um which highlights in each area what
supporters are available including the
torridge area
um my only reservation in in so far as
equip sheet is is some of these elements
we're not expert in so pension credit we
we don't know you know that they have to
we can sign post to um agencies but I'd
be loved to give advice because it's
just not our area what we can do is
refer them to the cost of living website
and other agencies that that may be able
to assist if they and quite to be quite
often we do do that if we have a brief
look at their income and we think it's
it's not right or not manageable we
often do refer them to other agencies
just to assess if they're claiming
everything that they're tight entitled
to but it's not I mean we don't
administer those sort of benefits via
storage so it's kind of not our area of
expertise so
I was just going to say there's also
different well-being events that are
being held in different areas there was
one in Merton a couple of weeks ago and
that got together lots of different
groups with the aim of getting
information out to people who wouldn't
necessarily know about things for their
citizens advice was there and Devon
carers and all sorts of different
Community groups to help people so if we
can try and get people to actually
attend those types of events and
counselors as well
I think I think the idea of having of
having
sufficient information to signpost
but not
sufficient too much information which
then starts people trying to give advice
which is not the role of counselors but
um I I think that's I think that's a
good idea quickly to wrap this one up
yeah just yeah as you say I think a
prompting system to make them think oh
yeah I might be and then they can go and
look and try and work out themselves but
just to cause that initial steer I think
that'd be very useful to have that on
and there's like the online calculators
that turn to us.com or something where
people can find out if they're eligible
yes Jameson I just wanted to to say
because one of the things that struck me
when I was going through the bench
benchmarking figures was the
torrage being taking the longest to
process housing benefit claims and
obviously the time
and I'll just jump in at that point and
say that is exactly the sort of material
that we pick up in the qbr when we look
at it and we and we will react uh when
we see that in the qbr because that's
what the qbr is telling us but
absolutely right
um it will impact on on people's take-up
benefit how long it is absolutely and
and we we see more detail in that sort
of area in the qbr anyhow in terms of
our our reactive time and what our
targets are again
it has to be seen alongside what your
target is right we need to move on
um
I've therefore struck out that that
first point second point which I think
is fairly straightforward the asset
management plan which is been
um
Chief exactly they came to speak first
um thanks thanks share so we've got uh
full council agreeder at the asset
management strategy
um in terms of assets and how those
assets and land and so forth is used is
a responsibility of community and
resources
um ultimately there'll be a process
where any surplus assets
within the strategy are deemed to be
used or utilized in some other form or
sold the decision of Community Resources
and ultimately this committee can call
in from a decision from community and
resources should it see fit do my
question is do community and resources
look at how we are managing the strategy
not taking decisions my understanding is
into I want to look my under my interest
was to look at how the council are
actually managing our assets not to take
decision apps for CNR to take decisions
on disposals Etc so that that was dealt
with within the strategy identifying the
assets and how they're being used by the
council
um for all those assets not being used
then the property Estates manager will
bring forward a plan of review so
ultimately things will need to form or
the council need to form an
understanding of condition of assets if
we look at this building for example and
how we might best use this building
repair costs Etc over a period of time
but that's a process that will need to
to be gone through
that's awesome
yes just a quick addition to that we
obviously have the property and asset
management working group which is
reported to about rents void properties
ongoing projects that we're developing
opportunities so that is actually within
that working group's remit who then
report to community and resources or
escalate things so I think that is
probably well covered and if issues are
not clear to members then perhaps it
should be channeled into the agendas for
those working groups so I think you've
got that one covered as well
I'm
my question is
um
at what point and who
scrutinizes to make sure that this
council is putting enough aside in its
forward budget to maintain the assets it
has
my tour my time so far in this Council
has been
um
dogged by not dogged but has been marked
by us grabbing bits of windfall money
that suddenly fall down unexpectedly and
oh yeah quite we will we will restore
this grade two listed building that's
about to collapse
um in a town not far from here I can
think of one
um that isn't a plan and a strategy and
there was no funding for something for
which we have responsibility for
therefore surely we should be asking
difficult questions because it's money
it's Finance
that's where I'm coming from on it
um
thank you chat yeah I was going to
wonder is the asset list also as part of
this areas remit because well I re uh I
got an email telling me what the asset
list actually is on Monday finally
because it's been out of action for
months and I looked at it and I don't
think it's up to date and I believe
that's something that um uh auditing
governance picked up my thinking was
that we were wanting to scrutinize the
process that was in place
I don't want to actually sit and
challenge each property that's other
people's business but actually the
process that's in place are we actually
um being realistic about the cost of
maintaining our estate going forward
I personally have a view but um the um
anybody else got a view on it
Council Bush be sat there very quietly
well I would share that view I mean I
don't very much whether we actually put
anything aside for a rainy day to
maintain any of these buildings if you
get this one as an example
um as it was alluded to you've got this
one which is attached to the library
next door apparently it needs I think
they've got identified works of about
six and a half billion pounds required
on this building alone well I don't
suppose we've got you know six pound
fifty set aside for a little six and a
half million I'm a believer that we
should know the scale of the problem
rather than bending over like ostriches
and seeking our heads in the sand and
thinking that it it it'll it'll become a
problem for some other Council on
another day
um that's where this came from Chief
Executive so
um chair now that's the piece of work
that the Estates manager will be
responsible for and developing
um but it's not at that stage yet to
cancel this just well I say justice
early this year
um approved the the strategy so that is
a piece of work that the Estates manager
and the Estates team will need to are
are working on
sorry just in terms of councilor rights
Point
um if you can let me know which asset or
particular thing you think is missing
I'll
yeah I was just going to say that we're
going to need to know what our assets
are before we can say when we know how
we need to repair them I propose on this
one that
this committee puts itself on a watching
brief
and we allow
the various processes to move forward
um
if at some stage in the future
once the asset plan and and everything
matures
we are concerned that there is a
financial
disconnect because the real cost real
future cost of the liability to this
council is not being properly identified
that
we actually then reserve the right in
that Financial context to actually uh
look at it and discuss it but in the
first instance we we stand back because
the process is there and we are told
that
once it comes out we should have
confidence in in what we see and hear
I was just wondering whether
do you look at the draft plan if you say
that that's
being worked on whether we looked at the
draft and then
before will it go to CNR or full Council
where will it go
I don't think we determine to where
where it'll go I guess the the ultimate
place would have to be full Council
because it'll be budgetary implications
for it so that's where it'll ultimately
end up whether it's she in our first and
any recommendations that's yet to be
determined because until we work through
the assets you can't determine what's
needed Mr Dengue
thank you chair
um I was going to say for for my lamb
Ministry review that that came out of
that sort of thinking when we were
looking a while back at I think land
that was scoped out by the the joint
working group for the joint local plan
but it I I like you explain and and to
add into what you're saying so that
we're not treading on each other's toes
it was very much within the the remit of
our framework which is to support CNR in
the you know the review of policy and
establishing and the financial thinking
so it is
I think a good idea to keep that
watching brief but probably you know if
things take too long then we're not
achieving what we hope to achieve by
asking the questions so we also probably
have to say what sort of time frame are
we realistically comfortable with
because actually some of the things I've
put on my list I've put on from memory
going back that didn't make the
four-year review
um because they go back that long so I'm
sure
another colleague of mine can go back
further but those are the things that
I'm thinking of as well that it comes
under kind of the of the terms of
reference I couldn't see that the um
do we have a time frame or a planned
time frame at the moment for this work
to before this work is going to
as you said ultimately land with full
Council
I haven't got a time frame um I don't
know whether there's a time frame
um ultimately it will depend obviously
we've got a small officer team dealing
with that and dealing with a multitude
of other things so
um I'll speak to Sean and the the team
to find out what they've
and how they've developed how they're
going to deal with it uh
yes
could I just request then that we have
that timetable for their sort of next
meeting yeah that gives uh the officers
time to think of uh timelining it and at
least then we'll know when to come back
and uh
keep having a look I think that's a very
I think that's a very good part if we
could if we could if we could have a
brief report just to tell us of what
what the time frame is in this whole
area
of the
Asset Management the the identifying the
fixing the the the the the the the
liability
and
we would hope to see
in that
um
that the liability in fact stated in
financial terms to the council going
forward to maintain
the assets that we have without what we
would assume we will see
if we don't see that
inactive support to CNR
um then
um I think we would be minded to
actually call for that work but in a
time being we will stand back and not do
so
um
because I would expect
a value to be put on the work that needs
to be done
to be included in any piece of work it's
not just listing what we've got that's
that's the easy bed it's actually what's
its condition and what's it going to
cost to keep
cancer age well what I would like to see
is a program that works yeah totally and
of course so if we could have a
um I think the point from this actually
is we we would we'd like a a short brief
just on what the program is
um
try to exercise uh yes so that's we're
getting an outline uh program
um I guess the the other point are in
terms of understanding the condition and
the costs of all the council's Ice Age
um that we're probably going to take
some external input because you know
even if you look at this building uh for
example it's not just simply a case of
uh what it would cost to patch up and
repair you'd want to think about future
use and things as well potentially so
it's not simply a case of having a list
and coming up with a figure it might be
a bigger program and a bigger piece of
work than just uh here's a list this is
what we think it might be is that is
that in is that envisaged in the program
already at the moment
the yes in in the strategy because it
identifies uh
the council's current use of different
assets and how they categorized and the
process for determining future use of I
say it's uh the current condition cost
to bring up to a standard and or
potential other uses or disposal because
of course we don't have the costs then
we as councilors in full Council cannot
make an informed decision if we don't
know how much something's going to cost
of
maintain or put right or whatever anyway
um interesting category casualism
thank you um obviously in August we're
having a strategic Workshop day
and I think this is one of those issues
that has got to be part of
the discussion about where we put our
priorities
and where we see these going forward for
capital investment
what funds we have available
all have to be taken into consideration
when we're looking at the vision for the
next four years and going further
forward than that because we I think we
all recognize that you have to plan a
little further into the future
because you can't achieve everything in
Year One
so I think we need to raise this as part
of that and see where we sit as far as
priorities are concerned because I was
reminded several times in the last
Administration we are a small Authority
and we have a certain number of staff
and if we want to progress things we've
got to look at the cost of actually
delivering that
so I think this is this is again one for
things are in place to actually
establish our prioritization as a
council going forward that that will be
a golden opportunity to be able to
include that
okay I mean
no businessman in their right mind
would be going forward without some
knowledge of the costs of maintaining
their estate
we put aside money
to replace our vehicle Fleet looking
forward 15 years
um are we doing the same for our other
assets
Council bushby
language Europe well
you mentioned our vehicle Fleet that's
an exact known quantity you know you get
a price you know exactly what it is
you're going to cost and you can budget
for it in terms of how to mention
mentioned the uh you know our Capital
program we know more or less what our
Capital program is going to be on new
builds at the Environmental Center et
cetera the problem you come to is when
you've got buildings like this of which
we've got quite a number where it's not
Capital it's repairs and renewals and
that's where you get that's where the ex
really expensive cost comes in because
there are so many unknowns the chief
executive is intimated that we will
probably have to go out and employ
outside surveyors to come in and
quantify exactly what it is uh you know
we're going to be spending and that
that's the unknown and that's what
really worries me because you've got a
price from one company and it's X number
and yeah it could be the next one is 50
less or 50 more
not a known quantity it's very difficult
like traveling the Seas when I don't
know how big the icebergs are and this
one's a big one
um and um
okay
um I suggest John that acid Asset
Management plan
sits as a footnote on our um
on our work program in that it is
something that we wish to monitor
carefully although we're not responsible
for doing the work
um and there is a
um
that there are clear budgetary stroke
Financial undertones to it where we do
have an interest
and
at least to
bring the problem to other people's
attention it may will then be for full
Council to decide whether they wish to
uh go down that route or weather for
Council is happy to continue not
necessarily knowing the full scale of
costs which may be Downstream ahead of
them that is for full Council but it's
our job if necessary to actually flag it
up and say uh we may have concern in
this area uh are we happier with with
that thank you moving on
um
homelessness strategy is
um coming to us
at the next meeting
on the current plan
is it going to be
um are we on target for that
I'm trash piece of uh part of a piece of
work we work into it's not ready for the
the next meeting yet
um it's part of a wider piece of work
around housing and obviously you'll know
there's a report coming to full Council
on Monday around housing
so I guess the the point to make is we'd
been dealing and actively managing the
problem because of the huge amount of
expenditure and the number of temporary
accommodation in advance of producing
any kind of housing type strategy Okay
so
when we get to it we're saying that this
in cycle three at the next meeting is
too early because it's not it's not
going to be ready we can't okay it is
something that we
will see the the draft on us and when
it's put together okay so that that
that's one definite that is that that
and that is you know in Council terms
that's a priority one I think
um
just taking him on the list so I'm not
pretending to put them into any priority
order grants maintenance councilor
bushby where you go
thank you chair
um grones maintenance it it really does
concern me
I'll give the concerns
um
as I see it now I don't think it's fit
for purpose
on the grounds that
um
a maintenance team is far too small
we've got six full-time employees and
two agency workers
to cover the whole of the torch area and
it is just not enough and you only have
to look around the fabric of the town
the park some of the outline areas to
see that you know they are just you know
overwhelmed by you know this this year's
scale
um by way of comparison the tenant
Council employs four four full-time
staff to look after that just the the
center of Biddeford and if we weren't
doing that clearly it would be adding to
Target's workload
um I think torridge needs to seriously
look at the numbers of people that they
are employing on grains maintenance in
order to do the job effectively because
as it is now
you know I mean the part the beds still
haven't been planted you know there's
compared to what the park used to be
like just you know 10 years or so or ago
what used to be you know the Jewel on
the ground now it looks totally
neglected I get numerous complaints the
cemeteries aren't being cut the grass is
two feet long normal May aside
um you know it was before that and it's
it's no sense
they need a far bigger investment and
clearly what we are putting to it in my
opinion
um chair I'd probably come back to we've
got a strategic planning day in a couple
of weeks time if that's something
councilors wish to prioritize as an area
of additional work I think there's some
other items on the list here thinking
about enforcement capacity and and the
like their things you've come to us wish
to prioritize certain areas and
de-prioritize other areas uh that would
be a uh you know for for fall Council
and councilors to debate and conclude or
not so it's part of that kind of wider
discussion I think
all right how much work do torrage
employed ground maintenance team do
outside of
Biddeford and Northern
you've got some in Torrington Andrew
I think you know before George took it
over sorry to Town Council were picking
it up and doing it very well so they
were shocked that it was taken away from
them so maybe that's an Avenue
okay
it's interesting and out in The Villages
the parish council's employ their act
and you know the the Civic Cemetery in
one of my villages
is paid for and maintained by
by people
um paid off the off the off the pre off
the precept
um
and uh
land so it was kind of that was kind of
the agreement okay so yeah
have you
is this something for us or not
I think this committee could
um look at we obviously took this back
in-house
and we had a a budget that we have been
funding
um Tivoli beforehand and when the
contract came to an end and we we
brought everybody back in
are we using
um
I'm just thinking about the capacity of
that budget
is it a question of
um do we have the right number of staff
are we utilizing the whole of that
budget or has it had to be targeted
towards replacement of equipment and is
there therefore
difficulties so I think it might be
quite interesting to actually look at
the makeup of what we are as a council
um our in-house provision was contracted
to do because I don't think we're 100
clear on that because we do have as you
say parishes and Villages who do a lot
of the stuff themselves and that is paid
for with their precept but likewise
our parents maintenance still
from torridge still
tackle different problems I can think of
you know the Westwood hoe green for
argument's sake beside the Promenade
Tori to responsible for that
whereas Northern Town Council do lots of
other aspects so it's about who's doing
what and whether we're making that money
work as well as it can be interesting I
remember scrutinizing Tivoli
what Tiffany Tivoli Tivoli on external
in the in the previous administration
quite early on uh we we had a good look
at that right it didn't make very
exciting uh reading
um and of course this is something that
has switched sides now we've taken it
inside taken it in hand
we have a more direct interest as to
whether we are getting
ultimately value for money
um for the money that torridge is
spending on this and whether actually
an adequate job is beyond enough of it
has been done
can I could I just quickly come back I
think the it dovetails in with another
issue you've got on here about
Recruitment and Retention and I think
that is perhaps one of the factors we
need to be made
aware of as to whether it is simply
um we we don't have enough or we can't
recruit or
what are the issues well what that one
doesn't know that until you get to the
point of actually looking at a report
and
um okay
yes
I'm wondering whether we should request
the climate emergency group to look at a
strategy for grounds maintenance and
then for them to bring their
recommendations here for us to
scrutinize as part of it because it's
not just about cutting the grass it
links in with the environment and
whether that includes planting of wild
flowers
no but that's why it comes that it would
come here so that recommendation would
be put forward in terms of the climate
emergency and biodiversity and then that
would come here and we would look at it
oh
oh our main justification for looking at
it is financial
I mean you know if you look at what we
do and why we exist and our financial
and are we getting value for money yeah
all links together because certain areas
you can mow around certain areas so it
looks well kept but you make sure that
you plant because in Torrington they've
done that haven't they with the help of
rhs rosemore and looking at how you
manage those areas with Native wild
flowers and that would impact on the
costs because you would only be cutting
certain areas and it works quite
successfully in other parts of the
country so I don't see why we can't do
the same and I think that would have a
financial benefit as well as well as
helping the environment
because chair thanks just to pick up on
a couple of couple of points and so in
terms of when the the contract was taken
back in-house obviously full Council uh
provided the budget and that the service
should be provided within the budget
envelope that was was the the previous
contract
um councilor Hudson mentioned about the
the equipment and the staff so this is
there's a separate equipment replacement
budget and informs part of the uh the
overall Service uh replacement so that's
kind of funded in much the same way as
vehicles and planting equipment
um there are a couple of I think there
are a couple of points that caused
problem this year partly Recruitment and
Retention was an issue
um that coupled with not more in certain
areas caused a further backlog in being
able to maintain some of the areas which
I know councilor bushby has made
inquiries about and has been discussing
with other with with the officers so
there's a there's a combination clearly
we could cut the grass every week but
there's a cost of doing that so It
ultimately comes back to what does the
council want from a service does it want
to prioritize Grounds Maintenance as a
service above other services because
it'll come at a cost if the council
wants to do that then it's about
balancing the budget
we might we make quite a play about you
know the pride of place
and how the knock-on effect of that very
that sentence pride of place if you take
pride in where you live it has a
knock-on effect in you know people's
well-being but it also has a knock-on
effect on you know litter vandalism
all of those other things that you know
we we all aspire to where you've got a
really nice environment people tend to
look after it when they see something
which isn't cared for
and clearly not much effort is put into
a particular area you only ever see it
go on one way and that's downhill you
have to keep peddling in this as you
have to keep if you're not pedaling
you're you're freewheeling and
freewheeling is going downhill we need
to keep
in my opinion we need to keep
all of our public areas in as good a
condition as we can possibly maintain
them we when we
when it was Tivoli
we were all highly critical of Tivoli I
know it's been suggested and I know this
is correct what's he the same you know
we have taken it back in house but more
or less the same budget that was
allocated to Tivoli well we've spent 150
Grand or whatever it is on new vehicles
mowers all that type of equipment but if
we're still expecting
if we're expecting a higher level of
service
and higher satisfaction around the
district but we're only still prepared
to pay the same as what we were piling a
failing contractor how is that really
going to raise the bar that's my my
concern I'll stop you back because we're
we're in danger of starting to try to
answer the question which is not that
we're not the purpose of this the the
my take on this is that it's not for us
to be trying to set up new policy or
whatever our role is to scrutinize what
the council has put in place
the council has put in place a new
arrangement
and
it is timely anyway that actually we say
that has now been running for how long
have we've now been had it in-house
two years it's probably timely from a
scrutiny point of view that this
committee looks at that and sees how
it's doing
in order to
if necessary report to
full Council or whoever if we felt that
actually it wasn't going as was envisage
that it's an act of scrutiny to look at
a process that has been set up and put
in place by full Council it's then for
us to look Downstream to say right is it
working
and it is is it representing value for
money
so I think there is something to be look
at here but
um not to try to develop new policy
because that's not our job it's
specifically to look at what has been
set up by by by Council am I right now
at you Chief exactly
um
well yeah well you're looking at the Q
the qbr so the qbr uh monitors spend so
at the moment I guess the spend will be
in line with what the council has set
aside for that uh that service
um I guess what we can't see is output
though in the qbr we can't see how well
or not it's been done we might be
spending the money but not actually
doing anything at all
no sorry so so if if we cut in the grass
in the same areas the same amount of
times as councilor pushby said if you're
using the resources and doing the same
uh that's not quite the same as wanting
more
um because I don't disagree with it and
so bushby is saying if you want the
place
every place to look great then you've
got to invest and put more in and that's
a decision for the council to take
through its strategic planning and what
does the council want to achieve rather
than saying
um
it's scrutiny because we don't like it
we perhaps don't like it
yeah
um
indeed could I could I just say I mean I
think the issue here is that
um councilor bushby doesn't actually
like agree with the policy rather than
the budgetary thing the policy which you
alluded to which was brought in with
the Wildflower
um the non-mowing
um you know only mowing around the edges
is something that cancer must be as very
unhappy with so I don't think and this
policy I don't know because I'm new has
maybe been in place for one or two years
or something and I don't
and I agree that you need to look at how
the money's been spent and
I agree with that but I think to say
well we're spending all that money and
the grass isn't being cut that's because
that's the policy and so this councilor
bushby has an issue with the policy
I I don't share
yeah we're looking at biodiversity and
the environment and what happens I I
think I think we can you know I agree it
can be made to look tidy by as as
um was was said by cutting around the
edges and all the rest of it but I think
the issue is as you are saying we need
to know is the money being spent as we
requested in line with the policy and
and we need to we need to look at what
is policy
what is the policy and is the policy
being carried out satisfactorily with
the money that's been made available I I
don't want to get into
an argument or detail about where we
know where we don't spent in line with
the policy that has been laid down so
I've got it just just respond to that I
think the the climate change working
group the intention was that they were
looking at areas that could be suggested
for wildflowering and making a
recommendation so that was part of that
working group to come forward which is
not
is the business of what we want to look
at I would suggest
because we have a new organization here
that the council has specifically took
in-house two years ago and it involves
money and it actually involves output
within the council area in other words
effect
and I think after two years it is right
from a scrutiny point of view that this
committee should actually
spend time looking at that to see that
it is as a chief executive said we can
see in rough financial terms through the
qbr but we also need to satisfy
ourselves that actually it is able
within that money is able to do what has
been agreed what has been tasked what
has been tasked to do I'm not this isn't
the place to argue as to whether
somewhere should be left wild flowers
and somewhere else should be known that
is policy that's been laid down
elsewhere it's for us to actually look
and see is that happening
um and it's a a and are we getting value
for money
um are we happy with that
right okay
so that is a review of the
torridge Grounds Maintenance system
both financial and alcohol yes okay
um moving on
um
Mr Harper Mr dengate
put the Jewel of the crown of the future
Crown
um on the list I'm
using their attention oh sorry
Recruitment and Retention
um
did this I have a question to ask before
you speak Council bushby and that is are
you referring to recruitment and
retention
Council wide or is it specific to one
local area
is is it 17 yeah
how does that compare with other
councils locally is that
and do when people leave as councilors
we don't find we don't have like any
feedback from like reasons why they've
left I think in other organizations
people like governors of schools they do
don't they for their teachers whether
that's something we might want to look
at
Mr help
I think we get some of this through the
qbr but one thing I really have a
problem with and I've had for quite a
few years is where do we understand
between the executive and the
non-executive
are we trying to run the council for the
cap for the executive or are we actually
looking at it and saying yes there's a
problem and then obviously at the end of
the day we have to the council has to
say how much money we're going to commit
to
recruitment into wages
I don't know that is this is for us as
as a as a committee we're sailing fairly
close to the wind the gentleman on my
left because
um uh the the Manpower within the the
council itself is a is the
responsibility of the chief executive
um so
um
I guess the the question that's been in
in
um certain people's minds for for a
while and certainly been in my mind for
a while and that is that there is
we we use
uh whether you call it we used to call
it
um
um gapping policy but whether you
whether you're using gaps in employment
uh either deliberately because you are
choosing not to fill posts
um or whether it's natural time that
takes that you end up with with gaps
whichever
the save on the Manpower Bill actually
is is a significant element to the
budget in that sense
um in that there is a there there is a a
clearly defined Manpower save within the
qbr now of course we all know that
either
if it's a
policy not to recruit
than before long you can't justify
having that post anyway because you're
saying what I do without it or if it's
just a natural business of natural churn
and you have the the
um the gaps in between and that's where
you you save the money
um uh in effect it's
it's that sort of knowledge that I think
people want to make achieve the
executive it's your area so
um tell us more chairs multitude
requests questions in there
um no we haven't got a policy uh of not
recruiting
um obviously we do we have a policy of
reviewing jobs when they become vacant
and determining how and how they may or
may not be filled there may be a change
in direction of the council for example
the lane in the budget represents
um just general turnover and where the
where there are gaps clearly in some
instances we'll plug those gaps
immediately with an agency member of
staff so for example
um if there's gaps in terms of sending
out a refuse round on the morning the
manager will ring the agency and get
stuff in to make sure that round goes
out
um I guess more widely and generally
recruitment I was talking this yesterday
at CNR I recall uh recruitment is
challenging right across the the public
sector
um people are choosing to leave
employment full-time employment and go
into agency and short-term assignments
largely because it's a lot more it's
paid a lot better so as along with most
other authorities are suffering with
having to pay higher wage costs for
having agency members of staff to fill
posts which we need to fill to keep
Services running
um unlike the the private sector it's
not a simple case of if you want to pay
more because the market is demanding uh
demanding that and your competitor is
paying more next door uh we can't just
hike up or add uh to the wage bill in
that sense because uh obviously there's
specific things around equality and wage
parity across across services and I
mentioned one example yesterday again in
our waste and recycling service where
we've been trying to recruit uh
mechanics and the like and they're paid
between 10 and 15 000 pounds more than
we are able to pay so it is a
particularly challenging environment at
the moment I think the other thing to
point out touching on some of the things
Council hankin mentioned and it probably
links to some of John's
um slides earlier we recognize that the
age profile of the area the age profile
of the the council is such that there
are a lot more people in the the age
older age group and that's one of the
things we've been trying to tackle
through
apprenticeships and graduates and we've
been particularly successful in doing so
um so I don't know if that answers all
the questions but that's a kind of thing
um
just uh chatting very quickly offline so
to speak with councilor craigie
um
there is a suggestion here that actually
we are we are we are reviewing the qbr
process later this cycle okay having
having been on the qbr process now for
nearly two years we are we are due to
actually review the actual qbr process
in December
and the suggestion is that actually
as part of that review
we look at
the feasibility or not
of measuring more more precisely our
retention or churn in as part of the qbr
as a regular thing potentially so we we
discuss it then as part of the review to
say is this additional data that we wish
to be informed of because it
um every now and then if
um churn is high
and then as a result there are
consequences because we can't fill jobs
and and because we're failing to retain
and we know that the the recruitment
Market is very challenging at the moment
as a result
things eventually start to Creak because
you haven't got enough people to do all
of those jobs
um
so the suggestion is that actually we
we wait and we take a more informed
decision when we actually review the qbr
process to decide whether this is
um
data that we wish to be routinely
captured and measured and shown in the
qbr because it actually has a direct
um bearing on the efficiency of the
council
councilor bushby
Michael Jackson that's exactly what I
want to talk about the efficiency of the
cancer and I wasn't going to mention
specifics but the chief execs already
done that so I I feel I'm able to
respond to that so this Council
shortly hopefully is going to be
spending a multi-million pounds on a new
Environmental Center up at the top of
East Water our new vehicle workshops
will be based there and hopefully by
that time potentially we'll have our new
vehicle Fleet there now if we go down to
the Wescom Depot for those of you that
haven't been down there I recommend that
you go down and have a look I mean it's
it's like like someone under the arc
down there but uh is that working on a
coal mine but
nevertheless the the issue that that we
will face we will be moving up to that
new new uh facility
with all the stated art equipment that
it will have we all have any staff
we've got one or two full-time mechanics
in Wescom at the moment and one or two
apprentices
achieve the exact's absolutely right
what he said trying to recruit HIV
mechanics
around this area the ones that are
working in you know the private garages
like Evans or whatever you know probably
on 12 or 15 grand a year and more than
what we're paying our guys clearly
if we're going to run efficiently there
and get value for money there's no good
burn your head in the sand we need to
take that take that task uh you know
head on and if it means that we've got
to really really look at our
um
you know our pay structure for those
specific types of jobs and you know it's
only those specific times so it's not
like you've got to up the pay of
everyone because there's a very specific
area of the workforce
in order to actually recruit some new
and additional staff to effectively run
that Workshop then we need to do that we
need to be recommended to achieve the
executive is to ask to do that otherwise
value for money is just going to grow to
the window and what's the point of
having you know spending five or six
million on a new vehicle Center base if
you haven't got any staff to run it
chief executive is going to answer this
one he's
um no I I know I think we all accept
this it's a challenging environment but
as I said it's simply increasing uh pay
and it's not just that that area we
struggle to recruit planners we struggle
to recruit Finance staff legal staff all
across the board
um and I would want to be faced with
equal pay claims from other members of
Staff because we have a pay structure an
agreed pay structure agreed with the
unions agreed through with the staff Etc
so you then start to run the risk if you
pay in certain certain staff more for
certain things of entering into equal
pay claims and faced with much larger
wage bills than but I I accept there are
certain circumstances and certain areas
where different things different things
can be implemented to do different
things are equally uh where in in some
instances that does upset the rest of
the workforce as well so there's a
there's a a fine balance and a fine line
to walk uh when uh implemented a
different pay for different sectors of
the workforce
what you're what you're saying but as
has been saying you are responsible for
uh you know the workforce so it'll be up
to you and your team to come up with a
with a solution but we cannot have a
situation in my opinion where we've got
our waste and recycling manager and I've
been down on numerous occasions to see
him and he's in his office and doing a
clutch on a truck or something like that
he must be the highest paid mechanic
that we've got in in the country we you
can't have that situation I agree
entirely Council break I think yeah you
mentioned equal pay and make sure that
we don't you know pay some staff more
than others doing the same role but we
already have contractors coming in and
are they on the same wage as the actual
staff
I think that's what I mentioned earlier
when we pay contractors come in on an
agency basis we're paying the the
external rate and that's why
um sometimes that's why recruitments
being is made more difficult because
people are choosing to go in the short
term employment sector and work in
different organizations because it's far
well in the in the current economic
situation is far more profitable because
people are thinking about what they take
home every week and not necessarily the
the long-term benefits of working for an
organization such as a council so things
like pensions and stuff don't always
come into the equation when people are
struggling to uh to earn my own
to the flip side of the coin of course
councilor bushby is that once the new
Environmental Center is built then
people will be working in a much better
cleaner more fit for purpose and
hopefully as a result professionally
happier place which may help
Inspire them more
um I'm going to propose though that
looking at the individual detail again
is not is not it's not our business but
what we there is a good suggestion there
and that is in my view and that is that
we need to decide at a later date
whether we actually want
whether this detail needs to be captured
as part of the qbr
and therefore I suggest that we actually
look at it in Greater detail when we
review the qbr as a suggestion that it
could be an additional line of data we
wish to see in the qbr of basically what
are our retention and recruitment
figures
um
I mean I think that's very pertinent at
this time you know we know that the
fluctuation is quite big so it seems
like a wise thing to monitor at the
moment when when Staffing levels settle
down and maybe it's something that
drifts off and we'd have to look at the
feasibility of of of how you would
capture that and and how much useful
that would be to us so that's all part
of the review and maybe the agency costs
of that quarter like how much more are
we paying than we would have paid if it
was possibly that would be for for that
discussion there is a there is a very
good discussion to be had there
um uh in indeed um
can I put that on a on on a list for the
qbr review
we got that one
okay
um
I'm interested uh Mr Harper Mr dengate
want to have asked that the Apple door
key Maritime Innovation into project uh
be put on the list
tell me more
it's a very large sum of money we're
getting from government which is over 15
million pounds
we did do another project actually in
holesworthy where we did run into some
problems and perhaps what we really need
to do is take an overview of this
project not to run it but to take an
overview of it
okay the the greed governance
arrangements for the project uh is the
property and major projects working
group
um and any Associated uh need to report
will go to full Council and we're
expecting an update uh to go to full
counseling to either the September or
October meeting because obviously things
have moved on so there's an entire
project team working on it there's a an
internal management team working on it
and then you've got the the major
projects uh property major projects
working group and that's the the
governance Arrangements we've agreed
with Department of leveling up homes and
communities
it's interesting as again
our interest
is
the scrutiny of
how the money
how the taxpayer money is spent
in that does it conform to
what people said it's going to be spent
on
um
what the project does it's not our
business and in that sense
um
and the interestingly properties and
major projects working group
is that actually a statutory committee
right it's a working group within the
Constitution okay
um
and so they are reporting director for
Council on
on
this particular subject so as I said the
full Council shortly
okay
um given the amount of scrutiny that uh
when you get money from government and
the reporting mechanisms you have to
about every
part of the spend I think this project
will probably be scrutinized by not just
property and major assets working group
but by government by filling in returns
and reports and if there are any things
that occur during that process because
it's not going to be oh well we're
sending a report in six months time
I dare say the it is regular monitoring
and returns that you have to fill in so
and I'm I'm maybe speaking completely
out of turn but having had money given
to projects in the past I know that you
have to be very accountable for it and
yes I recognize that in hindsight a a
project that this Council delivered
didn't have that level of scrutiny but
uh things have changed and moved on and
I think we are much more regulated with
our spend
so I I I don't know if I'm speaking out
at 10. I
I would I I entirely endorse what you
say I I if anything a role for this
committee
maybe in years hence once the actual
project is complete and then this
committee looks at how well it's
performing
and is it actually delivering everything
that we hoped it would do that might be
for another day and a different thing
I'm
I'm with Council Larson on this one
um can I have a view as to my my
thinking is at this stage and as the
chief executive pointed out there is
agreed governance arrangement for it my
thinking is that this is not on our
radar at the moment not it not in its
formulation stage later perhaps to see
how it's actually working
we're happy with that
okay that not on our list at the moment
okay uh Mr Harper annual statistics
I think that's already been dealt with
we've done that haven't we really
um
really just in that in that in that
presentation and
um
drawing our attention to the the value
of the benchmarking material as well
um uh we're really getting it
okay
Mr Harper again storage Finance
I think when I look around and I've been
talking today about what we've talked
beforehand about how much you've
actually got in the finances and how
much money we've actually got in
reserves
and we are in a not in a dire situation
that's the wrong thing but we are very
tight for money
um
I would like to have a look at some of
things like the services level
agreements how many have we got I know
we got one for the Burton and we've
gotten the others do we actually go one
for the active torrage which is comes on
later on
Chief objective okay again there's two
sides to this is a roll of external
scrutiny in reviewing what's being
delivered through service agreements so
in terms of what we've got yes we've got
uh one for the Burton we've got Cab For
example and a couple of other small
grants as well as the services provided
by active storage so
um full Council allocates the the budget
so this this committee scrutinizes the
budget at that point in the time frame
and external scrutiny review whether or
not the organization is delivering on
the services that have been paid for so
around value for money so that's kind of
where they sit between the both
committees so
this committee through the allocation of
the budget during the January February
meetings we'll consider
yes I
I'm actually happy with that explanation
take active toriage out of that list at
the moment we're going to look at talk
about active charge later
um
I think that actually as it is at the
moment we we catch those things as we do
the budget scrutiny I mean at that point
we can see what is being allocated to
now
um
and having sat on external and listened
to the Burton Come and sing for their
supper on external um uh and um
um and justify or not what they're doing
which is um
I'll be
passing judgment on another committee so
I won't but it it's um so I mean you
know they are scrutinized in that way
um
I'm not quite sure where what extra what
more you're wanting
um
I was clearly look at the finance of the
whole thing not necessarily what they
deliver but I'll be actually getting
value for money for our from the amount
of money we're giving the service level
agreements well you can actually say
that if you're looking at what at the
output at the delivery true
um and and that is I mean potentially
there is a rollout for joint work with
external
um or or that when external look at
um
an organization like the Burton where
there's a service level agreement
we are giving torrage cash to it so we
have an interest in that
external because the Burton are
providing through that a service to the
area that they have an interest in
looking at that potentially uh we have a
joint session on that but um
yeah I was just going to say all of the
meetings are open to members of the
public so if there's something specific
that you are concerned about you could
attend the external meeting and then
I'm I'm I'm not convinced around the
room
where are we going with this one
yeah I think so I think so I think we
leave that
um
okay
um strategies
um
homeless homelessness we are looking at
anyhow when it's ready
and we that is that is
um put in
um
economic strategy for torrent
talk further on that one
I think through the qbr that have quite
a number of years now I've been asking
have we actually got us a
a plan
uh strategic plan I haven't seen one I
know that we've got one now with with
North Devon and other partners
but what we haven't seen is is this and
I think sometime back
about two years ago we actually I may be
wrong actually paid someone to do some
uh start preparing this plan
the same as Estuary as well is we've had
a working group
um a task and finish group
we actually agreed that yes as far as
we're concerned and it was put forward
to us that that would then be
incorporated into us into a a strategy
an economic strategy
um but once again that sort of
disappeared again or I should say it's
it's
dormant chief executive uh chair yes we
we've had a recovery strategy after
covid which we did with North Devon and
the teams across both councils are
currently working on the Northern Devon
economic strategy which um I believe is
due to the uh finalized towards the end
of this calendar year that the start of
next calendar year it kind of fits in
with the kind of wider strategic things
I'm thinking that's going on
um and well obviously form part of
things like letting up Partnerships and
so forth so it's it's it's been it's
currently being worked on with the teams
across the both councils I guess in
terms of time frames both councils had
spent an inordinate amount of time
preparing and submitting bids for for
leveling up funding and High Street
funding so obviously North Devon had
funding through the high streets program
we submitted to women's
two pieces of work one which didn't go
very far and then obviously the Apple
2001 which is progressing so in terms
and they're the same officers who are
doing those bids who are in the economic
strategy but it's in hand and due to the
uh brought to both councils I think in
New Year
and specifically entitled what Stephen
Northern to have an economic strategy I
I I would imagine so it's it's about uh
the opportunities across Northern Town
we've got a joint local plan is largely
recognized that we've got a single
economic area across Northern Durban so
it makes sense that we have a normal
Northern Devon economic strategy they'll
undoubtedly be elements within their
specific to each of the councils because
we are separate councils and there's
different things that we'll be working
on so such as the maritime before that
goes to full council is that being
looked at
in a draft sense by a
counselor-led group
I'm quite sure that the timeline for
that was
um proposed for the development of this
strategy actually said that there has to
be a period of consultation
and this will be a wide consultation
with all all the partners and I should
imagine
it's an opportunity for us to look at it
here as well and for counselors to
comment and understand what is being
proposed and I think some of the
elements of the well all of the elements
of the economic strategy that relate to
torrage will be part of our our
strategic workshops because these have
got to be incorporated into our vision
for the next five to six years so it's
it's all coming together so I think
we're
I hasten to say you know because you you
think you've got on top of it and we're
actually heading in a a good direction
to actually bring these things together
rather than having a lot of loose loose
ends so I'm I'm confident that I think
this can be achieved I think we have to
see that in its draft consultation form
um
John
yesterday was just about the second part
of the query about the Estuary strategy
and I can confirm that that is on the
economic
team's business plan for this year it
was on last year but other priorities
took reference but it is definitely on
their business plan for this year
because I checked we spent a lot of time
talking about Estuary in this committee
uh or you do it in external as well
don't you
I get confused between which one I'm set
on so
um Estuary again
um we we would wish to see when it's in
it when it's in it in a a draft form
um we will have a comment on that
because we spend a lot we've spent a lot
of time commenting on it in the past
um happy that
right okay moving on
um
so Mr dengate that Inc that covers
estrogen Estuary strategy
is your first point
it pretty much covers it
um I think the points have been made but
there are some themes around the
environment around the use of Harbor and
um use of partnership all of which we've
touched on and the things have moved on
it would be good to see how the
recommendations from the Estuary
stressery review play into those
recommendations now because I think
they're all relevant and they've all
kind of gone up a level yeah um and I
think going back to the
the you know the environmental not the
environmental the um
that was all clean one that that is
surprisingly on the Estuary and so you
know it yes it does come into Focus it's
one of our key
um assets that I use the word even
though it's not ours
um that we've got and so the S2 strategy
was
a review after well it was originally
done in 2014
um for members that haven't been on the
committee port and so we did a review in
2021 to see how it had been going
um and then to kind of put forward
recommendations of which a number of
recommendations were made not just
um obviously it's going to The Economic
Development Group but a lot of the
recommendations were made so this is a
piece of work that this committee has
done what I'm suggesting is saying
not you know so what but how's it going
we absolutely we want to we want to see
how it's progressing and
taking in
the developments that have also been you
know how that's going to be impact yeah
I think that's that's what I would say
um on that one so yes that would be it
and and the rest has been I think
discussed and said but there were some
you know there was a lot around the
environment and other areas that people
may want to pick up and look at the
report and recommendations it was the
September 21 meeting
people want to see it
I can confirm that that all those
recommendations from this committee have
been passed on to the people actually
reviewing the Estuary strategy so they
have got that as background information
and again it's it's time frame isn't it
because that was two years ago the
recommendation so it's a question of
and there's been a delay understandably
but then at what point will that come
back
so we're coming up to the 10th
anniversary of the original strategy
it's purely down to priorities and
workload again and then since that's it
would be good John if we can get a if we
can try to get an idea of a date as to
when that may be
able to be to be seen looked at uh
purely from a programming point of view
uh on we go Mr zengate
um so that the club neutral Target not
to say anything that the council have
agreed or not agreed it's just that it's
it's six years away if we're working
towards it
are the cost implications are there any
delays in the working towards it and
does that mean the nearer we leave it
the more expensive it's going to become
so it's going back to what you
originally said on asset programs you
know have we got visibility of the
exactly what it is we're trying to get
to because I think on the last qpi went
backwards rather than forwards so and
that was with making quite a few strikes
towards it so the question is how are we
doing
and you know we've got six years what's
the cost implication
if we do it in six now what if we wait
three years what if we wait one year
yeah yeah
um so that was what that one was about
just just all within the terms of
reference around supporting
yes correct so on this one in particular
the progress towards the carbon neutral
Target
um
is that something that uh
are we cross crossing anybody else's
work that
um I guess only the climate change
working group
um but that doesn't mean they don't mark
their own homework no just no just don't
they're just gonna oh sorry exactly
I don't see any reason why an apogee
can't be brought to say you know what
the council's and I know we've done
updates for all Council periodically so
I can't see any particular harm but I
guess we just need to speak to the our
joint officer to make sure we kind of
programs in appropriately
um so we have a that's a a an update on
progress
um uh good yes
um still with you
wasting Recycling and intense not so
much on the Environmental Center
although that's obviously an important
asset but just the QPR
the Figures were trending backwards a
bit so it's just a question of have we
kind of saturated our policy or is there
anything within the policy that needs to
be reviewed in terms of you know are we
is there an efficiency inefficiency
issue around that or is it just it's
kind of got to its best that it's going
to be
that that's working that was a kind of
more around the waste of management and
I think we've picked up on it I think
um I think the the
it was the last qbr report where the
figure was down a bit but generally the
trend hasn't been no generally it's been
very good good so actually we should
wait a while just to see if that is by
exception for one reason or another I
don't think it's probably a fair
a trend to suddenly start wanting to
lifting the lid there when when just
because of one one one dip in a
otherwise
um positive trajectory was that the gun
noise because they were someone to do
the good weather meant that we were
cutting less therefore
the explanation of actions around it as
well it was the it it was the other
other elements of waste which were down
as well also but it was just a question
of you know again that fed into the
environmental and the target side I
think I think I think monitor but but
how long is it going to take us to build
the Environmental Center
I hope to see it in my lifetime
you know I'm confident that
dressing with this
obviously um I mean the the the the real
interesting time will be out and when
it's it's built
um whether there's any change to to
Output
Etc
um with with more modern facilities but
that's a different day
um
I think uh Steve on this one as a qbr
item we just monitor for the time being
we just internally we flagged it that
there's been a dip but we need to wait
to see if actually there's a a it turns
into a trend and if that's the case then
it may be timely to for us to ask
questions but at the moment not
um that's fine happy with that yeah no
okay
um on we go so you again policy review
race that and it may be that it doesn't
work within Council but in in certain
not-for-profit organizations you have
policies key policies which the ball
keep an eye on and I guess one of the
policies that this committee is
responsible for or are they not any
um full councilor generally responsible
for the policies so we keep a register
with in each of the the service plans
for each of the service plan managers
I've got a record of the policies within
their area and the dates for review and
update obviously any key strategic
policies or responsibility of all
Council
it would be the process and not the
content that you want to look at I'm I'm
just thinking like you want to satisfy
yourself that one of the chief
Executives just talked about actually
runs efficiently and we we raise gdpr a
while back and I think that kind of
brought it to the Forefront it was been
there anyway but it was kind of it
gained a bit of an impetus I guess it's
just a question of what's there and
what's what's on the horizon if you
don't know the gaps if you're scanning
you don't know what you're looking for
you don't want to keep coming up with
ideas or suggestions when it's already
covered but it's it's around Finance
again as well but it's if we're
reviewing policy or helping inform on
policy and we don't know what the
policies necessarily we're supposed to
be focusing on it's just so hence I
wondered if there was a specific remit
but
it's just what comes so like the PID
reviews a one-on thing and and so we
wait for it to come to us rather than go
looking for it
um
anybody got a thought on it
particular View
this is really the the process working
the the working process of council
itself and and
to do that does there need to be a level
of scrutiny in making sure that
the council in its policies is is doing
things at the time when it says it's
going to do do it um
chief executive
chair that's probably that is a role for
the audit and governance committee
because as our Auditors look at
different uh looking at the different
services and what's happening they will
check to ensure that their appropriate
policy is in place and if there's not
they'll make a recommendation to the
audit and governance committee that a
specific policy might be out of date and
needs updating so that's the committee
that's responsible because that's where
all our audit and Assurance okay um
I mean there's nothing there's nothing
to stop us calling for something if
there was something that caused
particular concern but
because I just wanted to ask uh is there
um policy list is it a paper form or is
it a digital one so you can kind of look
for especially and say oh yeah this
one's coming up because it's gone red
because you know two years two weeks
later
or is it just that you've got a paper
one with a dates written on it and
you're just going to flick through and
find a new look
you think it's devolved down to
all right so he said that each each of
the um the Senior Management they've got
a policy book and it says which ones are
you know coming up for review or
whatever do they have is there a digital
version of that or is that just purely
on the paper that you know people are
writing in whatever dates approached
with each within each of the services uh
service plan register so each of the
services will responsible
specific policies
is captured with within that so that
then feeds into their work program for
the year if for any reason anything
hasn't been done and it's picked up by
the Auditors who are looking at all the
controls policies and procedures in
place uh then that's the kind of check
if you like
is that a digital form or is a paper
form because obviously papers are much
easier to accidentally mess whereas if
you have some some kind of
I just want to say yes it's electronic
it's an Excel spreadsheet
um it's it's linked to the business
planning so it's reviewed at least
annually but it's actually reviewed more
than that as happens and I'd say the
other thing is that you your committee
do look at policy development because
we've set up a social value group to
develop a social value policy when it's
necessary so I think I think you have
got it covered I'm I'm happy that I
think are we all happy that I think so I
think we're happy
um
so not to look at at the
policy review register or what what our
system is peer review next one
when did we last look at this
um chair um the leader and I are in
discussion with the local government
Association about when our next peer
review will take place and we meet in
this week as well so we're probably
expecting that to be next year we leave
that to the leader and a chief executive
to sort out um
as and when it's decided then we will
have a role but um not until
um
okay next
um discretionary versus statutory
is
of course
that's awesome thank you I think the
members budget working group are the
ones who are closely scrutinizing every
aspect of the council's budget
um and whether it is statutory or
non-statutory services that are being
offered so I think that I think that is
being monitored and reports are
therefore fed up to Fed Up yeah it's fed
up I get fed up with it
passed up to full Council so
um yes I think it is a major issue and I
think it is important that everyone
understands the difference between
the things that we like to do the nice
discretionary ones that we fund against
what we have a statutory duty to fulfill
and the public don't understand that
necessarily so it is important that our
counselors understand it and it's not
just us and we have hard decisions to
make
it's interesting that the budget through
the budget working group sort of grows
wings as it goes on in yet it was set up
to identify savings
um and then suddenly it's taking on more
and more and
um and of course it's not a
formal
statutory grouper such as it but it is
it's a working working group approved by
full Council to look at the budget and
ways of balance of the budget which I
was just going to say it's kind of
interesting talking about discretion it
doesn't have a scrutiny function though
no no so talking about discretionary and
statutory expenditure obviously we've
been talking about Graham's maintenance
we've got uh planning enforcement we
talk about Economic Development all of
these things are discretionary
expenditure all the nice things uh
active towards
well many of the things yes absolutely
I was just going to say that it's not
black and white because
we have to follow our strategic
priorities as well don't we so it's
following the Strategic priorities some
of that is discretionary and it's not
just nice to have because they are
Necessities even though we call them
discretionary I think that's the wrong
term for it I don't believe that there's
an area of gray with to overlap and then
there's
luxury but there is the fuel
discretionary but then there is that
making good because we have to meet our
strategic priorities and we can't meet
of a strategic priorities if we're just
following the statutory obligations we
wouldn't meet our priorities would be so
we do need strategic priorities have
been set by ourselves
and arguably
you can't set yourself a a strategy and
then say oh well
um therefore that forces us to fund it
from Eric I I wake up from
um
don't I'm going to stop you there is
there an area for scrutiny here or not I
didn't know how it linked to this
it's something we're only just starting
to see really I'm tempted to put it on a
monitor list and let's just see how it
goes we see it you know we we can see it
every quarter through the qbr anyway uh
and and see how things things are going
and um
well I think there's more more falls
under the member of the budget working
group but the more important question is
when's that starting up again you know
like most of the Zoo members probably
don't even know what it's about
um
now I I I
draw Brett on that one and I'm not the
chair of that group the leader of the
council is the chair of that group we
have had
um a period of time for the month of
August we are looking at doing the
Strategic
workshops we've brought that perhaps
forward but it's a question of making
sure that we can get everybody and I
should imagine that will reconvene in
early September
um with representation from each of the
political groups sitting on it to make
recommendations and looking and examine
and obviously people are welcome to sit
in on the meetings
but that working group
oh yeah I'm committing our leader to
something at this meeting but I should
imagine and I'll refer to our chief exec
that we're planning it for early
September
which I agree with the deputy leader and
I've been having discussions with the
leader about about getting it set up and
you know lead members are only appointed
at the last full Council and as Council
Hodgson mentioned we've got a strategic
planning day coming up so it all needs
to kind of pitch together
um I think we monitor on that timing but
not hard for the list your next Point
Land register review we've covered
really yeah already covered that uh and
your last point on the list child
poverty in torridge the ash report
wanted to call
the children
so at this point we're one of the three
key areas
so it is an indicator
but it does
showing in his services
I I would contest that those figures
aren't necessarily
linked to
finances or funding that storage
necessarily it may be it's more likely
the issues of The Wider economy
Etc so is that more external than
internal
yeah I I I would have thought I think
that's external rather than internal
actually
um
okay
next one I put on the list
which is
um
I say enforcement capacity enforcement
both in planning and
Environmental Protection over the last
four years
I've become
aware that our
um our capacity in these areas
um he is often not great for various
reasons
um but
the especially if you have
um if we have an explosion of of
planning work which we've had over the
last two years
um and a significant increase in income
as a result
um
planning on for instance planning only
works if if it's enforceable
and
enforce and and the only way that
happens is that actually you've got
people who can investigate and look into
it I would like to know
how big the problem is or not
um and I've had it mentioned on on the
shop floor out there in the sticks as a
counselor it gets mentioned to me all
the time do you have the same yeah and
it was brought up at the planning policy
The View out there is that we do nothing
now this is not necessarily correct but
we do nothing to police uh the the the
planning system here all we do is
approve plans or or whatever thereafter
other than building control
nobody gets involved and even if and
even if there's a problem there's nobody
to do anything about it so why do we
bother reporting it that is the view out
there in the stakes now that is an
unhealthy view it's also a view that
encourages people to actually go their
own way and I can assure you if you're
not living in a in a urban area with
lots of people overlooking your plot
then that is very much often what
happens
um
are we underpowered from an enforcement
point of view given the amount of
planning work that currently goes on
I'm not aware that we've include
increased our capacity even though the
output on on planning has increased
dramatically these are questions that I
was um
and and also in a same way Environmental
Protection
and the Environmental Protection
officers who I have a lot of
uh uh connection with through planning
um are always telling me that actually
what they can't do is they can't follow
up to see whether actually what's being
said is is being is happening
um
is this a view that's shared by others
or not
I'm just going to ask how's the 106
monitoring fee come in and change the
game on that
because I thought that was kind of the
point of it
which I I can't remember when but
recently a report was brought to this
committee providing updates on planning
enforcement numbers case loads and
things
um I don't know if
I don't know if John can record sorry
John or Tom or somebody but councilor
bushman's got an input on it so I
and I think we all recognize the
importance of it
um it I hadn't realized it
hang on
disabled now I I may be wrong you might
have gone to CNR actually I think you've
seen hours they came to us
through a report but
as as mentioned it was also how
the the kind of fee was going to help
believe some of that there is a line in
qbr
yeah however that doesn't refer to
capacity or the scale of the problem or
not I think it purely tells you what I
think it might be what's going on around
so it might be narrative around the
question that was raised I think you're
right I think there was a question
raised around numbers all right yeah
yeah on the qbr last time or the time
before I think a separate report was
taken to CNR as well if I remember
rightly because I they I remember
um Council bushby just an observation
with regard to the topic you're talking
about the planning was the second I
believe the second highest income stream
of torrage after car parking so it has
to wash its own face in my opinion I
agree
remind me that
um our planning manager brought the
report to CNR around the introduction of
it was a introducing monitoring fees
within the the section 106 for this
purpose so if you're absolutely right
councilor bright I think enforcement was
brought before but under a separate
report but when the budget
um and call Council were looking at
budget and fees I think she brought that
report forward to specifically there
would be a fee for monitoring 106 is
going forward
186 is
yes from fee for monitoring 106 is we're
talking about people building houses
which haven't been approved or
um uh which is there's a lot of that
goes on
um
I think it's important to understand the
different types of enforcement that the
council is responsible for
um and when we're talking about uh do we
have adequate provision for different
types of enforcement the section 106 is
a very specific
um
uh monitoring of conditions of planning
applications and whether or not they're
being complied with
enforcement comes in in many different
guises you know down from dog fouling to
All Sorts so we have a wide spectrum of
enforcement responsibilities and it's
understanding
um what we're prepared to
fund that when we're setting our budgets
correct
um because there are things like
derelict buildings which are dear to my
heart living in Westwood
with problems there have been derelict
buildings in other parts of torridge
that have had to be dealt with
um and it's understanding the cost
ramifications of enforcement action and
again I think it's helpful we have our
legal advisor here tonight who has often
stressed to me that you know your
decisions and your to progress something
have consequences
and it's important that the council
understands this when we're pressing for
more action in any specific area so I
think it's important that we monitor
enforcement but we need to have an
understanding of the types of
enforcement this is not just the section
106's I think we can get we can get
carried away and think we've solved this
but it's a wide spectrum it's
considerably wider I would I
I don't know whether we've got a problem
why I'm saying is actually though that
we we should see
uh it's a more detailed data of to to
have an idea an informed idea as to the
scale of the problem or not in different
areas
um and um
I've just picked up on what people have
said to me but
um I think it's something worth
um could we ask for a briefing note on
the types of enforcement that we're
responsible for that we the council are
responsible for and you know what the
various caseloads are
and the funding that's made available
because they will have individual cross
codes I assume because they're probably
fall in different areas of
responsibility and I'm looking at
our chief exec on this front
said it'd be easier to narrow it down
because we we do have
um enforcement in many different areas
some are statutory and some are
discretionary planning enforcement
discussion yeah it's discretionary yeah
we have some statutory new sense
enforcement but we then also have
private tenant housing enforcement
um there's a whole way you know we a lot
of the Environmental Protection side
some of that's a discretionary element
we have Community safety elements you
know that's all enforcement as well so
it is a a massive spectrum of of of work
I I guess part of the answer is we've
got a massive area to cover I know with
the planning enforcement team they've
got a huge area to cover and they could
be in one side of the district that
takes an hour or two to get to to go to
and so I I guess whether that's
something for your strategic planning
day as to whether
members want to decide what areas they
target I mean we're happy to bring
something forward but it's it's it's
going to be a big bit of piece of work
it would be better to identify what
actual areas
um you are specifically concerned about
because enforcement is just wide-ranging
we've got this traffic enforcement
officers as well so you know every
Department you I think I think I think
I think I think
but I don't think
um you know we've listed it quite a lot
there
that you've gone through
um that everybody is aware of all our
responsibilities
or not
um
okay and it it may be that by using the
enforcement word we've suddenly trying
to you know touch everything and we as
we know that enforcement comes in
lotting perhaps we should just
prioritize on the key major areas
one is
planning enforcement inevitably I mean
we have a you know the planning is a
major function the local planning
Authority is is a major role of this
Council
um
and
as I said I mentioned Environmental
Protection but um
I think your pun
I do it
oh yeah I mean obviously enforcing on
private sector rented
um properties and keeping them up to
standard is a big area that uh has been
relatively little enforcement off
in the past I mean if you're not careful
we're going to create such a major piece
of work I think it's probably best to be
looking at the enforcement in different
areas separately
um obviously I've used uh one of the
reasons why my latest suggestion is
about that Environmental Protection of
spaces because fly tipping and dog mess
and things like that is always one of
the ones the the pet irritations of
everyone isn't it and it's how how we
make sure that planning
has a proper level of enforcement but
also making sure that we've got proper
policy around how we're tackling fly
tipping and enforcing dog control orders
and um
prohibition on drinking and things like
that in the in town centers
like a job
I would have thought that planning
enforcement is nearly always going to be
complaint LED complaints by the public
where they see illegal building or you
know someone's in breach of uh you know
clearly breach of a plan that's you know
we react to that and I don't think you
probably need to have too many staff
that you know in order to fulfill that
role but then you've got the other side
of enforcement where you know we as an
environment Health Department in the
council you know we have a taken as a
statutory duty to go around all of these
establishments that are you know selling
food and drink beverages or whatever
like they all have to be inspected well
clearly that that is a role where you
have to have a certain number of people
in order to do it given the you know
size of the area that is there so you're
right it is a it's a wide-ranging role
but uh you know the easy one is the car
parking you know is it something is it
something that we should be actually
asking for
elements of it for a report on
each other
comes out some you've got a view area
it's it's one of these questions that
um
you know you say about complaints
um there are complaints about different
aspects
um of
a perceived lack of enforcement
that we are dealing with so I think
those things ought to be talked about
and ought to be discussed but whether
this is the place
um I don't think so I think this is
about budgetary requirements and budget
setting and the implications for the
authority
if we make those decisions that they are
a strategic priority and perhaps this is
a workshop decision that needs to be
made
rather than us scrutinizing what isn't
being done
or is being done
just in terms of planning and those
links with the parish councils I know
Helen Smith and Ian Roland are happy to
go to the parish councils and they did
last year and shabia I believe in the
planning to come to petruckster in
September so maybe that's the way to
sort of build those relationships and
cover different issues that there's a
lot of it I think does come from the
parish councils and there's a lot of
apathy they feel like
there's lots of apathy out there that
it's not worth complaining because
nothing will be done about it yes there
may be more information going out will
help some in some way but it does go
beyond that because there are bigger
issues of enforcement
um
but maybe that could be part of it
just the principle of uh of scrutiny
they beat me to a lead and own this
scrutiny process on behalf of the public
and voice the concerns of the public and
Community I suppose the question is is
that what we're saying this is or is it
not well
and I'm just going to pick up on what
councilor Hodgson says on the first
point under terms of reference for this
committee review and scrutinize
decisions made or actions taken in
connection with the discharge of any of
the council functions including
decisions taken by the Community
Resources committee or by an officer
it's actually wider than just Finance
but um
there so
um
I think we need to do some more work on
this I think too that the the word
enforcement just suddenly made it so
wide and I think we need to do probably
some internal work just to come back to
to the com to committee perhaps with a
more refined proposal if we do so and
one that's achievable in terms of a
workbook because at the moment we've
actually opened up a complete Hornet's
Nest with a a never-ending list of
things I I realize that
um we just kind of have headline figures
from each of the enforcement that just
kind of give us you know some idea of
how many complaints they get how many
they deal with for each each of the
individual
um enforcement groups and then just come
back with that and then we can say right
that's clearly an obvious thing we need
to Chase from those stats that might
give us a bit more of a steer
well
we'll discuss it further John and and
come back with that um I think in in
time I don't think we're gonna We quite
got the information and in order to make
a decision now
um moving on my other one which actually
really is to council Donald hankin as
well
um
active torrage
will at some stage need a ruler passing
over it
um a from an output point of view which
is most definitely external
um but also we have an interest which is
actually linked to an earlier but very
specifically linked we have an interest
and that is the assets the torrage
assets that active torridge uses going
forward
um in that we can get
for instance you might have a very Rosy
very good picture from the operational
side of active torrage and that's good
but
under their feet it may be that the
assets that they rely on to to operate
are going to crumble in
five years time or whatever and
therefore it's got to be a joint look I
was going to propose that we have a
joint session with external at some
point where because I would imagine you
will be wishing to look at active
torrage as a new organization before
long so we can look at both sides of it
come as part of the room that does go to
external and from what you've been
saying with the assets we've already
sort of covered that under the asset
review the asset plan so it sounds like
that falls under the asset plan because
that would be the same for all of the
assets within turret it just happens the
active towards yeah but we have yeah
okay my my issue was we have a company
that we've set up which is utterly
completely dependent on certain I'll
declare an interest because I'm on the
board Factor yeah
chief executive I'm a director of the
board so I ordered interest as well
um obviously the council the council has
a contract in place with active storage
to supply the buildings for a specific
period of time to run the service run
the Leisure Services from any review
would be towards the end of that
contract in consideration whether that
contract should be renewed continued Etc
okay I think Stacy is going to add a few
so yeah the other thing to add to the
chair I'm not nothing to do with active
storage I'm tourist District
um we lease that to active torrage so we
lease all the buildings to active
towards but torridge districts have
maintained the full repairing liability
so that's still under us
through the lease so we've got a repairs
team that will go in for that reason to
maintain the buildings and properties
under the lease
so under the asset management plan
we will presumably I'm coming to you we
will presumably therefore see
the
estimated costs of maintaining those
facilities
for
a period of time
presumably Council bushby
you're absolutely right
in terms of the buildings whether it's
Northern hoes really Taunton or whatever
they are all expensive buildings to to
maintain and to improve and they're all
full of equipment which
you know has a you know a finite life it
just you know whether it's the boiler
system you know heating systems
the equipment that's within there they
all will probably expire and need
renewing within you know seven to ten
years on on a rolling program so you
have to
as a council we should be setting aside
a sum of money into a ring fence fund
where
you you have a sum of money which which
you you can draw down should the event
of any of that equipment you know fail
otherwise if if you haven't you know
actually budgeted for it
then the money's gonna have to come out
of you know somewhere as an emergency uh
payment so obviously you need to you
need to plan for that
I'm sure we do but you know I would say
and for the new councilors who haven't
been around I've I've
made the point on a number of occasions
over the last four years that
I don't have a view people think that
I'm against it I'm not necessarily what
I want to know is the detail so that I
can make an informed view take an
informed View and decision and until
somebody tells me how much it is going
to how what the life of these swimming
pools are and how much it's going to
cost to keep them like that or to
replace them because we were told not
long ago that certain of them are liked
I've only been told half I and every
other Council only been told half the
story and
so we need to know and that's why
um
you know I've always I've always
um pushed to say will somebody please
tell us actually what the realistic cost
of maintaining these assets
for I mean if we've sat on this this
journey presumably there's expectation
that we're going to provide swimming
pools the next 20 years what's it going
to cost to actually keep the assets up
and running for the next 20 years
share some of that information was
presented to full Council during the
last term so when we were exiting the
contract with the the former provider
there was conditioned surveys done of
each of the buildings and that
information was presented to full
council at that point in time so there
was two elements long-term uh costs and
the short-term dilapidations that we
needed to discuss with the then existing
occupant
um yeah equally as I said as part of the
acid management strategy plan that
information will need to be gathered and
at a point in time said when the
contracts do for review renewal that's
the point in time when the council will
decide do we still want to invest in the
service and in the buildings to
facilitate the services that's the point
that those discussions considerations
are are made at the moment as Stacy said
the council's leased those buildings to
active towards to provide the services
for a term
uh you could look at it in purely
contractual terms I'm actually
wanting to look at it more as a at a
expectation of our population as to
whether this is which is this is going
to a service that we're going to
continue to provide
that's one of the point sorry I forgot
to mention
um within the the budget there was a
some
um included in the financial strategy uh
for continued uh maintenance of the
building I can't remember off the top of
my head what it what it was but I
remember within the capital program
there was a son highlighted and reported
to members that would have been in a
budget report in February Council
breaker thank you chair I completely
agree with you and um Doug bushby are
both saying you know we need to know all
about what these what the buildings we
have uh and what the liabilities are
what's the risks and we need to know
about all of them not just the swimming
pools because you know this building
ain't cheap to repair either you know
the Pioneer Market again isn't cheap to
repair we landed on some funding there's
loads of them and we used to look at the
whole list I don't really see why we
need to look at just swimming pools
alone so it cost a fortune okay we are
the answer to our question or the
questions raised by me and others is
that we will see
we'll have visibility of these costs in
the asset management plan
because
so we don't so
yeah
um
do you agree with that yeah yeah I agree
with that
we know it is we know it is
absolutely absolutely I said I I just
I'm just I'm just worried that oh it
wasn't on the record it's a success
story and it's going to get better we we
we know that counselor uh
um I'm just worried I'm Keen to be
reassured that the assets that you are
dependent on will still be there in the
future
um because
um that's my concern
um okay
um councilor craigie bidford first of
all
um for new councilors um I'm sorry this
is turned into a bit of a marathon but
it's important stuff as we just talk
through these and get an idea of what we
do and don't want to do
um
in order for a meeting to go on Beyond
three hours we have to vote to continue
to take the meeting
a proposal from councilor bright and
seconded from the chat that we take this
meeting Beyond three hours uh can I have
a show of all those in favor please
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten so ten ten four uh against well
other enough I give up
won against I Surrender
okay
what
[Laughter]
I was just going to reiterate again
about external being open so if anybody
from internal wanted to understand the
performance of a specific
group then you're very welcome to come
and attend or see it on YouTube
or you can put forward questions you can
email me and I'll put them forward at
extern and I suspect this next one is is
for you anyway but Council agree uh yeah
I was just gonna say that I'd like to
obviously review the security the
Biddeford CCTV system as it's sort of
the biggest element of toridge's
contribution to the community safety
partnership Northern Devon which of
course comes up at externals group name
um but obviously a lot of the
Environmental Protection uh work that's
done even if councilor bushby recently
managed to catch an offender
by using the system no sorry that was a
private system
okay fair enough but by by being able to
access a uh recordings yeah
um and obviously it's a quite a
successful system for Community safety
in it and it'd be uh good to understand
the system role and see what the
policies around it are
views on that well I completely agree
but I was hoping you'd widen it to all
the CCTV that Toro Jones because
Torrington has some CC view as well
which is not storage owned but uh
recently we couldn't catch someone
because the cameras wouldn't turn
I'm more than happy to to open it to the
whole of Torres it was just that it was
just a bit of the ones that I was
thinking of at the time I suggested it
that's all
right um Chad guesses what what what he
what were you considering reviewing do
you just want some information that says
these are the cameras that are in place
these are the times of monitoring
I'm not quite clear what
what is your your seeking to scrutinize
I guess I mean what is the current
strategy with CCTV cameras what is the
the aims that what's the council trying
to achieve with them uh how much is it
spending on achieving that objective
and uh
how often does it review where the
locations of cameras should be
there's lots of elements of a uh
Community safety partnership policy
can I add to that the actual capability
of the equipment we've got whether it's
still functional or not
whether the staff are trained to use it
TV it's the places
um we we again it's it's a question of
funding
um so we had some funding to to install
it and that that comes at a cost ongoing
um if members decide they want more CCTV
um then that again is something for the
strategic planning day it isn't our only
area of community safety it's a an
assistance to the police and and again
questions are whether it's a torrage
liability whether it should be a police
liability we do it in partnership with
the police but it isn't actually our our
responsibility again so again it comes
back to what's members priority if if
it's we want more CCTV cameras we want
the manned 24 7.
um you know it's all achievable
but it's at a cost and an ongoing cost
um so we have protocols and policies in
place the police can request it under
um protocols they do requests that we do
directed surveillance on on occasions we
can do all of that yes our staff are
trained again it's how many do you want
do you want them monitoring the screens
24 7
um so again it's all different questions
for members really
equip
the equipment mainly is police is it
in conjunction with the police that's in
the Biddeford Police Station
um they this is external work they
record all the time
um you know we can direct the cameras to
to move to certain but it's whether you
you want that 24 7 or
or not I mean you know it's a wider
question really coming a bit of a based
counselor's view Council bushby I hear
what Stacy said but I I wonder at them
why
um Richard hayster or a wasting
recycling manager is the officer with
responsibility for CCTV if it's a
torrage sorry if it's a police system
and it's monitored in the police station
what's it got to do with us and why
we've got an evolvement
I think what happened historically and
originally most CCTV
um equipment was funded through home
office grants and given to many councils
and I think many councils accepted that
probably without thinking about the the
longer term impacts of running costs
operational cost replacement costs so I
think it's kind of
um crept if you like over a period of
time and then councils have replaced it
councils are monitoring it it's it's
again something the police don't
necessarily want to do
um but jointly between councils and
police kind of recognize that somewhere
between us we have a responsibility
for Community safety because and that
area specifically comes under external
anyhow
the the community I mean yeah we've got
a community safety partnership oh you've
got the partnership there and Toby comes
and and briefs you and everything else
so the October I think that
that can be debated by all councilors
then and go from there
I guess it comes with Craig you want
some specific information and if you
want to have a chat with when the
officer is just to understand rather
than bring in reports to committee if
there's a bit of just detail you want
then
um that's certainly something I I I
suspect that if we if one wanted a
specific report on it then that is a
that is a role for external rather than
internal because they're already Linked
In very
um
precisely with the community safety
partnership Etc and it's all it's all an
extension of of that
um there's always written questions to
full Council Maybe that might be that
that's a way of answering questions as
well without having a huge report come
back isn't it so A9 question yeah
we have
you happy James at the moment that um
pursue that in different different ways
not for this committee though at the
moment okay
next one now empty homes policy
yeah um obviously uh councilor bushby
again with the sort of peer statistics
that got supposedly 925 empty trains we
get obviously with the qbr a report of
how many come back we don't have any
statistics of how many become empty in
the in the period
so it's hard to sort of look at churn
and obviously with a review of uh
housing policy uh obviously what you do
with the existing empty drawings is an
important policy area within that
it also has a huge impact on local
Community
Pride and well-being and
occupied or going semi-derelict or
unkept housing actually really pulls an
area down anyway
and starts to then launch into all sorts
of other areas and whether it's
squatting or antisocial Behavior et
cetera et cetera
um
I think this this is and especially in
the light of the the housing crisis we
have at the moment Etc
um
do we know is empty homes policy being
covered under the housing strategy
that's been developed
I guess it all depends on what you mean
by empty homes first of all you've been
empty homes and developed homes that's
something obviously we have second homes
and there's nothing that we can do about
that
um
empty homes and enforcement again you
know we can take enforcement action but
to follow through we we can jump in and
do the repairs and then obviously there
is a bunch of tree implication to that
something that I am really Keen to push
though is um some work that we've been
doing with lendology
um so they will loan people in all
different circumstances money to do
essential repairs to help bring them
back into fruition so that's something
we've got a report coming to full
Council shortly on the housing stuff
that we're doing
um recent um more recently with the bids
funding but something that is secondary
to that and I would like to do um is
this lendology and really push that out
there and entice people who maybe don't
have the means um to do repairs
themselves
um to come forward and and lendology do
really good rates and they will defer
payments forever or until they're just
deceased and offered so that's something
that I think we can really really work
on and then maybe if they're because we
do have some very sad cases where people
have gone to nursing homes of the
um next of kin don't necessarily have
the authority to deal with the property
and the parent themselves doesn't have
the money to deal with it so that's the
sort of circumstances that we can jump
in and maybe assist with this landology
and then on the basis that they they may
potentially lease it to the council for
help help with homelessness as a whole
so that's something that I'm going to
bring forward when we've got over this
first tranche of
um funding and the other projects of the
full Council coming on the 31st of
January
because the bushby
I totally agree with what Stacy said you
know there are certain times when it is
almost impossible to intervene for a
number of reasons but I think there are
there must be some easier targets within
the town that where we
where we can at least
try to intervene even if we don't get
anywhere and I'm probably going to sound
like a stuck record now but I've said
this out every time this comes up in
bridgen Street just a couple of doors
down from wetherspoons there's a large
building there with eight finished
Apartments done to a high standard
allegedly although I've never been in
they're empty they've been empty for 12
years they don't pay any business rates
they don't pay anything at all but
they're empty they've even got car
parking around around the back why
they're empty God only knows but they've
been empty and I've built it up it's
Bridge trust owned property they lease
it to a finance company over East Water
who choose to keep the building update I
know not why I cannot find out why but
in this day and age it is absolutely
immoral you've got eight properties
right under the center of the town
which aren't connected to Mains gas or
electricity or water which is why
they're deemed uninhabitable and they
don't pay any any rates
we're losing out the public are losing
out it's a
any more guidance
okay I guess we can we can have a look
at it as part of the holes in piece of
work and you know I understand what uh
councilor bushby said but there are
there are
some areas where work can be done but
um I know where it's been looked at it's
hugely resource intensive for very
little
outputs the other end in by experience
so
um should we just I think have a look at
some of the workers safety's doing
um consider the the numbers because uh
the numbers of where the derelict etc
etc and consider the problem before we
start saying we need to throw huge sums
of money I think we need to have a look
at some of the things that come to
bushby's advice just can't think uh that
they wouldn't be liable to pay anything
um because I I would have thought that
there's things in place which deem them
having to pay an element because all the
council tax rules are around the things
like that have been tightened up so
that that's that's right you might be
right that's what I'm saying I don't
know but I would have thought there
should be something in place okay
right
um
if this helps at all and if the chair of
external agrees as well it might be
worthwhile if I have if we ask lendology
to come and do a presentation to
external o s and explain what they can
do and the assistance they can provide
and that that might help guide the
committee a little bit in terms of
some empty homes and develop properties
again I think it's a committees look
wanting to know the scale of the problem
you know you can there's some there's
some big figures that are thrown around
but as we know that lots of lots of
those that that those figures have been
captured from somewhere
um
and I mean we can all counselors we can
we can all Quote examples of properties
on our patches which are empty not
derelict and uh and are are not second
homes in the fact they're not Holiday
Homes they're just left empty for
whatever reason and uh
perhaps we should be exploring whether
there is more that we could do to
actually bring those get those
properties back into service
um and um I'd be tempted actually to say
that we should ask for a report
um on
the scale of the problem and also the
the the what can be done so that we can
then actually we're better informed to
be able to then
either ask for more detailed work or or
to actually
see whether we can we can nudge the
system to to be more proactive in
certain areas
you agree with that
that's a key area priorities and this
links in with that and
um but I mean yes there is a there is a
need to to you know it doesn't cover all
all the properties we accept that but
there is there will still be a
considerable amount of property out
there which potentially
um
could be brought back into service
so that's a yes on that well I just
endorse yes I mean empty homes are
something that we looked at a lot in the
past and also is a challenge back to the
council through the corporate peer
review in 2017 that more effort needed
to be put into that so I think it's
right to pick it up
hi okay can I just say as well and the
qbr there was obviously a target of
returning four
um back to use uh obviously after five
years of zeros there was no explanation
why there suddenly was a Target which
implies that there was at some point
consideration of our policy okay
um just in the context of like putting
affordable housing on land that we own
which is causing a lot of controversy
within Torrid even just a small number
of houses isn't it so if we can bring
back some empty homes into use that's
we don't necessarily need to build on
those areas then that we own because
we've brought those houses back into use
and it's making the place a better place
to be because you haven't got derelict
poems to look at and causing other
issues absolutely right infestations it
spreads into all sorts of different
areas
um okay we will we will call for a
report on that
um okay last one is
you've got Economic Development yes
obviously we've got uh quite a good uh
Economic Development uh team in torridge
um but uh what the qbr seemed to be
lacking was any indication of what they
sort of return on investment to the
torridge is from all the spend on the
economic development
um obviously if you're facing investment
decisions
um you kind of want to know how
effectively you're operating at the
present moment to see whether we need to
be doing more
or less
I'm not even clear how we would do that
um obviously on specific projects so if
I use the the Apple door Maritime
Innovation Center as an example because
that's the the current one when you when
you submit funding we have to estimate
what the outs outcomes are meant or
intended to be so that's kind of
um generally easy because you've got a
project and there's something measurable
um General economic activity
um I'm not quite sure how we would
measure that
[Music]
um
anyway if you like
[Music]
um
because there are other parts of work
kind of discussing stuff with
communities and things like that so it's
easily measurable on specific projects
but not necessarily the team what are
they generated if you like
quite difficult when a project quite
difficult when a project doesn't have a
a commercial angle to it and therefore
it's you are because you're having to
quantify value which isn't necessarily
Financial value there's other other
things that come in as well so very
difficult bit of and if you think of the
the investment that was put into doing
something like 86 yards left sure no
nothing yeah
yeah
councilor bushby we should also be
looking at the commercial properties
that the paint that the cancer does on
on the Valley Road industrial estate etc
those are all developments were you know
the officers have been driving that
forward which I I would argue has
brought huge benefits economic benefits
and they employ a lot of people you know
there's a an awful lot of self-employed
businesses uh in property that is owned
by terrorists of cancer so that is a
huge bonus
okay and that's already reported so it's
reported to the property major projects
um on a basis and obviously forms part
of the income in the qbi I mean we can
see for instance we can see the income
from kazdan uh in the in in in in the in
the qbrid we are seeing that yeah this
this committee made a recommendation
some years ago that when those leases
come up for Renewal they have to be
renewed at uh commercial value at that
point or if not a separate decisions
required by the Community Resources
committee to offer it lesser Market
rates
my auto right when when our new
Environmental Center is built
there's going to be additional land
available which hopefully will be able
to develop as more commercial land which
we will own but which we will be able to
lease out
that's correct
um
therefore I I think now sorry yes it's
just gonna add to that point it is a way
of almost saying you've got a pound
spend which is the one that's going to
give you the better return
yeah as you say it's not always a
monetary value because there has to be
other implications but it's trying to
evaluate one of those judgment calls to
make that investment over another
investment and yeah there's probably a
piece of work around that because it's
not an easy one in a public body to to
really
bring forward because there'll be
different views as well
we we will we will leave that at the
moment then
um right I have a proposal this has been
a a monster meeting
um and and inevitably going through
these so well we've actually discovered
where there is or where there isn't work
and also what this committee can or
can't do in certain subjects each of
these things that we've looked at and
agreed have different time frames
attached to them and we can't actually
put them into our program until we've
actually worked out what the realistic
time frame is certain things are based
on when something's going to report we
need to do more work together with John
to to actually find out when that is
likely to be and then we can look at
dropping it into the program at the
relevant time I propose that the
committee
um agree that I together with James and
John
go through all everything that we've
we've talked about this evening and
those things that we've actually agreed
to take forward and we we work on
putting together a program we can't do
it now because we've got to work out
when all of these things come available
and we then
um we will put together a program which
we will then circulate to you there will
be an opportunity for you to comment
otherwise we will press ahead with that
program and it will be reviewed of
course at the next meeting so there will
be the opportunity to fiddle with it
then but I can well see that you do not
wish to sit here any longer whilst we
now try to put a certain of this into a
program
charity United if they could be part of
our meeting because if we're gonna
call in on resources across the council
and I need to just know what they might
be well I I I I said John and therefore
I I meant you know they they they they
um the council as well
um that if that is if if that is the
case then um we we will draw this this
this lengthy but uh important uh uh a
very useful meeting actually to a close
to the new councilors uh who've sat very
patiently looked rather stunned uh and
and inevitably quite a lot of the
discussion has been based on uh Legacy
or corporate knowledge uh which people
have had from before
um but I hope that you've you've found
it interesting albeit
um uh probably slightly tiring
um
that'd be the case and
um I declare meeting codes thank you
very much